alors comme vous le savez mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour appelle
l'audition de notre ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères être cher
Catherine Colonna qui est ici et qui se
prête pour la quatrième fois depuis
votre prise de fonction à cet exercice
de rencontre régulière avec notre
commission alors je dois dire que
c'est
c'est vraiment nécessaire que vous
veniez et que vous nous parliez parce
que nous sommes quand même je crois
cerner par un ensemble de dossiers de
défis de difficultés sur lequel je crois
enfin si j'en parle pour moi-même je
pense que c'est vrai pour beaucoup de
nos collègues règnent une assez grande
perplexité voire une assez grande
inquiétude sur la situation
internationale et notre capacité à
y répondre non pas que nous soyons
défaillants mais la situation ne se
prête pas facilement à une ligne claire
efficace entendue dans sur la scène
internationale alors ces dossiers on les
connaît d'abord il y a la guerre en
Ukraine
la guerre en Ukraine bon les deux belles
hygérences sont à ce stade dans une
posture de combat qui écarte alors
conviendrez je crois hélas toute
perspective de négociation à moyen court
terme et il y a même cette inquiétude de
savoir si dans une situation où
l'Occident ne peut pas accepter la
défaite de l'Ukraine et où les Chinois
semblent avoir des difficultés malgré
des attitudes qui ont été variables
d'ailleurs à accepter la défaite de la
Russie on est dans une situation
d'équilibre qui nous paraît inquiétante
et sur ce plan là moi je vous pose
d'emblée la question pourquoi
l'Occident les puissances européennes
les États-Unis aussi nous sommes nous
tardons tant à mettre le paquet en terme
d'aide à l'Ukraine nous sommes très
clairs nous sommes pas tous d'accord ici
sur les options mais globalement nous
sommes très clair sur ce qu'il faut
faire c'est à dire qu'il faut aider
comme l'a dit le président de la
République les Ukrainiens a
reconquérir
leur territoire ça implique me
semble-t-il que il faille mettre le
paquet on a l'impression que partout en
Occident on mégote on met pas autant de
chars qu'on voulait je trouve qu'il y a
un manque d'impétue
il y a la solidarité mais il y a un
manque d'impétus dans ce camp là qui ne
s'explique pas parce que si on raisonne
en termes de politique de d'efficacité
il faudrait effectivement je sais pas si
vous êtes d'accord avec cette avec cette
perspective mais mettre le paquet pour
permettre à l'un des deux belligérants
évidemment celui dont nous approuvons le
combat de de marquer des points et de
créer une situation nouvelle qui permet
de déboucher sur la paix deuxièmement
nous avons la situation très difficile
en Afrique
nous avons nous avons reçu d'ailleurs
avec beaucoup d'intérêts notre
ambassadeur
revenus du Burkina Faso qui est venu ici
et qui a fait une analyse à huis clos
extrêmement intéressantes et nous
mesurons à travers cela et nous l'avons
mesuré en écoutant le président de la
République
préparé son voyage africain à quel point
la situation est difficile et ce voyage
africain lui-même
[Musique]
nous interroge enfin on a on a dit que
on mettait on finissait
renoncer à la France Afrique c'est pas
une information nouvelle mais ça a été
développée avec un beaucoup de détails
d'analyse de conviction par le Président
de la République et on a vu un voyage où
on allait voir quand même des
personnages certainement tout à fait
intéressant mais monsieur monsieur Bongo
à la veille inscritain avec tout ce qui
s'attache à cela ensuite
monsieur Sassou au Congo et une
interrogation sur le degré de notre
implication au soutien de des dirigeants
légitimes de la République démocratique
du Congo donc tout cela crée une sorte
de situation là aussi nous nous avons
besoin d'être éclairés alors nous
comprenons très bien que moi je suis de
ceux qui pensent que ce n'est pas du
tout la faute de la France
nous avons ces difficultés en Afrique je
crois que c'est un peu l'application de
la loi de Tocqueville qui disait que
c'est quand les choses quand les abus
disparaissent qu'ils sont le moins
tolérable et donc on a effectivement
changé les choses et on a affaire à des
interlocuteurs qui manifestement ne
répondent pas très très parfaitement à
ce que nous ce que nous espérions et là
la solution on maintient on maintient
les bases on les ouvre on les transforme
tout ça on a une grande interrogation
sur le dossier africain même chose et là
encore le dilemme est terrible en
Afrique du Nord où nous avons une double
difficulté avec l'Algérie et avec le
Maroc difficultés qui se nourrissent une
autre alors que nous cherchons
effectivement à avoir de bonnes
relations avec le Maroc et que nous
avons des liens qui sont
de tous ordres essentiels avec l'Algérie
donc
on a aussi une inquiétude sur l'Europe
au delà de la guerre du crâne on se
demande exactement ce que on va faire
quel articulation de sécurité nous
proposons pour pour
[Musique]
l'Europe nous voyons que l'OTAN et est
reparu mais qu'est-ce qu'on va proposer
quelle est la contribution la loi de
programmation militaire n'est pas
entièrement clair sur ça quel est le
degré de contribution que nous que nous
apportons à un ensemble de défense qui
passera nécessairement si nous voulons
être sûr de sûr de notre avenir qui
passera nécessairement par une
affirmation des Européens par rapport
aux Américains non pas par méfiance mais
simplement parce que il est possible que
les Américains soient beaucoup moins
solidaires de nous demain qu'ils le sont
aujourd'hui de l'Ukraine nous avons
également une inquiétude extrême au
Moyen-Orient
sur sur l'Iran comment percevez-vous la
situation en Iran à la fois la situation
intérieure on a l'impression que les
manifestations les mises en cause se
calme mais quand même temps et
j'aimerais bien nous aimerions bien
avoir votre analyse là-dessus un
ébranlement considérable du régime au
sein de la société iranienne a eu lieu
et en même temps nous avons ce terrible
ce terrible défi nucléaire vous aviez
attiré notre attention notre dernière
visite sur le fait que ça ça serait
quelque chose de très qu'on était au
bord d'une rupture est-ce que là on
n'est pas on n'a pas basculé dans une
rupture avec des risques de conflits
extrêmement important d'autant qu'au
même moment nous avons une situation en
Israël qui est rien moins que
satisfaisante ou je crois qu'on peut
dire que la la politique de Monsieur
la politique israélienne combine un
succès géopolitique de première grandeur
parce qu'ils ont établis les relations
avec les pays arabes etc ils se sont
dégagés de l'étau international dans
laquelle ils étaient prisonniers depuis
le début et combiné avec une sorte
d'effondrement
des fondements morales parce qu'il
paraissent s'éloigner des principes
démocratiques assez fondamentaux qui ont
été les leurs jusqu'à présent et donc on
a là une aussi une inquiétude enfin on a
la Turquie
là c'est nous avons su le centre de
crise n'a représentants du centre de
crise et nous avons vu le l'action tout
à fait positive qui a été qui a été
menée mais nous voudrions bien savoir
comment vous percevez les relations avec
ce pays également avec l'Inde on regarde
notamment de la de la guerre du crâne et
je ne parle pas de de la Chine
qui effectivement j'en ai dit un mot
tout à l'heure est-ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment que après avoir été
très très prudente vis-à-vis des Russes
les Chinois qui se sont pas en train en
tout cas c'est ce que les Américains
c'est ce que les Américains donnent à
penser les Américains ont la même
politique que que au début de la guerre
d'Ukraine c'est-à-dire que ils ont
décidé de publier leurs informations et
leurs informations c'était que les
Chinois
s'apprêtaient à donner un sérieux coup
de pouce militaire aux Russes et ça
évidemment ça recréer un équilibre ça
pourrait recréer un équilibre au profit
des Russes qui ne favoriserait pas la
paix comment percevez-vous tout cela
alors vous êtes au milieu de tout cela
nous sommes au milieu de tout cela parce
que c'est et donc c'est dire à quel
point il est il est très très heureux
pour nous de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
et à quel point nous attendons de vous
que vous que vous nous donniez des des
éclaircissements des réponses
quitte à faire part de votre perplexité
là où
elle s'impose mais en tout cas c'est une
commission des affaires étrangères
extrêmement inquiète qui vous reçoit
aujourd'hui
merci infiniment monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés et de
votre invitation et monsieur le
Président de votre présentation elle dit
combien les défis sont nombreux et
combien
nous devons nous parler et échanger pour
tenter de mettre un peu de d'ordre dans
ce qui paraît bien désordonné
comme il s'est passé un certain nombre
de choses et même un nombre de choses
certaines depuis que nous nous sommes
vus à la fin de l'année dernière
permettez-moi peut-être de revenir sur
un certain nombre de grands axes des
événements de la vie internationale sur
les dernières semaines
je ne cacherai pas comme vous que le
contexte est difficile il suffit de
penser à l'Ukraine vous l'avez dit en
premier lieu je le dirai volontiers
après vous pour ce qui concerne
l'Ukraine les événements qui se
déroulent sur la ligne de front
on le voit depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant et en particulier autour de
Dark Maud mais pas seulement puisque la
Russie fait pression tout le long de la
ligne de front nous rappelle en effet et
nous rappelle après un an de guerre que
la Russie n'est pas dans une logique de
négociation
rien ne viendrait accréditer l'idée
qu'elle envisage pour le moment mais
qu'elle est toujours dans une logique
d'agression et d'annexion et donc devant
ce constat nous devons être à la hauteur
de la détermination du peuple ukrainien
pour aider l'Ukraine à faire face faire
face c'est ce que fait l'Ukraine
avec courage
et nous avons l'occasion les uns des
autres je pense régulièrement de faire
part de notre admiration devant la façon
dont le peuple craignant défend sa
liberté et son indépendance
le crainte fait face à une situation
tout à fait particulière peut-être sans
précédent depuis
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
qui est que un membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
Bafou et ben faut ouvertement les
principes les plus fondamentaux de la
Charte les Nations Unies que ce pays en
tant que membre permanent et censé faire
respecter encore plus que d'autres après
y avoir adhéré comme tous les autres
l'assemblée générale l'a rappelé dans un
vote clair à une écrasante majorité la
veille du jour anniversaire de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie le
23 janvier
de plus
le présent Poutine exerce depuis
un an également un chantage sur le monde
qui est un chantage à l'insécurité
alimentaire énergétique qui est
inacceptable le tout servi par une
propagande qui se déverse partout et en
essayant toujours
d'inverser les responsabilités de
justifier la justifiable je l'ai vu il y
a quelques jours à peine en Inde au G20
la Russie fait partie du G20 ou le
ministre des étrangères russes sargueï
la brosse à tenter cette étape après le
G20 lors de la conférence du raisinat
d'un dialogue a peut-être un public qui
était différent mais il a tenté en
séance les propos sont vérifiables de se
poser en victime et continuer d'asser
d'un certain nombre de contre-vérité
choquantes et je mesure aussi mes propos
d'une façon fort diplomatique
alors que l'on sait la vérité la vérité
peut-être que nous la connaissons
c'est une vérité tragique je dirais même
effrayante celle de plus de 10 millions
de personnes déplacées dans une partie
de réfugiés en Europe beaucoup de
déplacés dans leur pays des dizaines de
milliers de morts civils des enlèvements
d'enfants une politique même dans les
vents d'enfants la destruction
systématique des infrastructures civiles
grainières des bombardements ciblés
délibérément sur les installations
civiles et puis vous le savez mais je
veux le redire des exections des
tortures des viols
chacun de ces actes qu'il s'agisse des
actions menées intentionnellement contre
des cibles civiles ou des exactions dont
nous sommes les témoins régulièrement
étant constitutifs droit international
d'un crime de guerre
si ce n'est de crime contre l'humanité
je rappelle pour mémoire que le
procureur général de la Cour pénale
internationale enquête sur les
événements en Ukraine sur la base de
crimes de guerre crimes contre
l'humanité et génocide il appartiendra à
la Cour pénale internationale de
qualifier les faits et de dire s'ils
sont établis dans chacune de ces
catégories mais je n'hésite pas pour ma
part employer parfois le mot
l'expression de crime contre l'humanité
tente ses crimes sont systématiques et
généralisées
ceci dit au bout d'un an et pour
[Musique]
ramener les choses certaines proportion
au delà de l'émotion je voudrais
souligner que le bilan tout à fait
provisoire la guerre n'est pas finie et
sans doute avait vos raisons monsieur le
Président de considérer qu'elle n'est
pas à court ou un moyen terme en tout
cas à court terme sur le plan de
s'arrêter donc le bison peut-être que
provisoire mais ce bilan provisoire
après un an de guerre russes en Ukraine
c'est d'abord et avant tout
le bilan d'une série d'échecs pour la
Russie l'amener un projet de conquête
impérialiste des choses ne se sont pas
passées comme elle imaginait et loin de
là je voudrais en donner quelques
exemples le Kremlin avait fait le pari
d'un effondrement rapide de l'Ukraine
était ce 48 heures ou 3 jours seuls les
généraux russes le seront et encore mais
première échec qui n'est pas tombé les
forces armées ukrainiennes tiennent la
Russie a dû se replier sur une autre
partie du territoire ocrinien et aucune
exaction aucune privation aucun crime
n'est parvenu à entamer la détermination
du peuple crânien à se battre pour cette
terre pour sa liberté et j'ajouterai
pour sa dignité
autre échec le Kremlin voulait détruire
systématiquement les installations
énergétiques pour faire de l'hiver une
arme de guerre vous m'avez entendu je
crois utiliser cette expression devant
vous lors de notre dernière audition et
faire souffrir la population du froid et
de la fin
or les Ukrainiens n'ont pas plié
à pied d'oeuvre pour engager les
reconstructions puisque dans un certain
nombre de zones l'Ukraine a pu commencer
d'engager la reconstruction et lorsque
je dis nous monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés ça
n'est pas seulement nous la France mais
les 46 pays et 24 organisations
internationales ou régionales qui ont
participé à Paris le 13 décembre dernier
à la grande conférence internationale en
soutien au peuple crainien vous souvenez
que des engagements concrets ont été
pris qui devaient être suivis des faits
entre le moment de la conférence et la
fin du mois de mars
ce montant
un peu plus d'un milliard et un milliard
en matériel et en don je ne parle pas là
d'aide budgétaire au macroéconomique
mais de tout ce qui permettait de façon
très très concrète vous l'avez vu des
ampoules des ponts des biens de première
nécessité un certain nombre de qui des
générateurs de transformateurs ce qui
permettait à l'Ukraine de tenir et
de contrer ce calcul russe que l'hiver
le général hiver ferait plié l'Ukraine
et j'ai pu voir l'effet de notre aide et
les débuts de reconstruction chaque fois
que je suis allé en Ukraine y compris la
dernière fois à la fin du mois de
février à Odessa c'était la quatrième
visite que je rendais à ce pays
autre exemple le Kremlin compter bien
sûr sur vous parliez de l'Europe
monsieur le Président la faiblesse la
division des Européens et là aussi c'est
un échec puisque dès le premier jour de
l'agression et je dis bien dès le
premier jour les urbains ont su réagir
faire bloc le Conseil européen s'est
réuni dès le 24 février et des sanctions
ont été décidées lors de cette réunion
du Conseil européen donc dès le 24
février
impulsion
française sans aucun doute nous étions
aux présidents françaises du Conseil de
l'Union européenne mais impulsion dont
il faut bien dire qu'elle a été et c'est
tant mieux reprise au vol par la
présence tchèque puis en ce moment par
la présidence suédoise et l'unité a été
maintenue il faut parfois parler et même
négocier pour y arriver c'est normal
l'unité était maintenue c'est cette
unité qui est une condition sine qua non
de notre efficacité c'est vraiment notre
unité qui fait notre force
nous savons poursuivi dit paquets dit
train de sanctions ont été adoptés
ils vise au total plus de 1200 individus
et 160 entités
individus et entités et non des moindres
puisque parmi les individus je dois
citer Vladimir Poutine ou Sergueï lavrof
mais aussi vous savez un certain nombre
de fauteurs de guerre de profiteurs de
guerre donc des oligarques des hommes
d'affaires des membres du Conseil de
sécurité nationale russe des généraux
des propagandistes et de nombreux autres
responsables impliquées dans les
enlèvements d'enfants par exemple dans
le dernier train de sanction
qui a été adopté la fin du mois de
février 3 personnes trois personnes à
dire russes impliquées dans ces
enlèvements d'enfants ont été
sanctionnés dont la dame je laisse les
par son titre qui est la Commissaire aux
Droits de l'Homme russe et qui est la
responsable à titre principal de cette
activité criminelle
d'autres personnes
ont été sanctionnées dont je veux citer
le nom notamment celui de ce prix
gaugine il vous comprenez pourquoi il a
été sanctionné
nous continuons d'ailleurs avec plus
d'intensité avec nos partenaires
européens à cibler des membres du groupe
Wagner et le relais qui sévisse non
seulement en Ukraine mais un peu partout
dans le monde notamment en Afrique nous
y reviendrons
les entités sanctionnées sont
principalement des banques russes
et d'autres pendent l'appareil
industriel russe je veux insister une
fois de plus sur le fait que ces
sanctions ne visent pas le peuple russe
mais les fauteurs de guerre elles
produisent leurs effets elles entravent
l'effort de guérus c'est désorganise son
industrie dans un an elles empêchent
d'accéder à un certain nombre de
composants ou de matériaux nécessaires à
la Russie pour poursuivre son effort de
guerre nous continuerons et nous
renforcerons ces sanctions
symboles d'une Europe qui s'affirme
et je réponds partiellement ainsi à
votre question sur l'Europe monsieur le
Président
qui s'affirme et même qui
après avoir adopté un agenda de
souveraineté c'est l'agenda de
Versailles des mondes sa capacité à le
mettre en oeuvre nous avions créé la
facilité européenne de paix et cette
facilité européenne de paix a été
utilisée et utilisée massivement pour
aider les pays européens à fournir un
certain de matériel notamment militaires
à l'Ukraine nous en sommes aujourd'hui
dans une enveloppe qui a été abondée en
fin d'année à un peu plus de 3 milliards
6 d'euros d'équipements militaires
fourni à l'Ukraine par ce mécanisme
qui ne fait que rembourser partiellement
les dépenses des états donc l'aide de
l'Union européenne et de ses États
membres sur le plan militaires et bien
sûr bien supérieur
autre exemple la Russie comptait sur
vous l'avez lu certains d'entre nous ont
pu le penser sur la le temps qui passe
la fatigue qui s'installe ou qui
s'installerait dans les opinions en un
mot
l'affaiblissement de l'élan
international de soutien à l'Ukraine au
peuple ukrainien ça ne s'est pas passé
là encore erreur de calcul nouvelle
erreur nouvelle échec et depuis un an
à chaque vote à l'Assemblée générale des
Nations Unies et il y en a eu 6 à ce
jour
nous voyons l'isolement de l'agresseur
russe le dernier vol a eu lieu le 23
février je l'évoquais
et 141 états contre seulement 7 et
on constatant quelles sont ces sept je
ne dirais pas que la Russie se trouve en
bonne compagnie
141 états donc bien au-delà des pays
européens
au nord-américains ont rappelé à la
Russie ses obligations on considérait
qu'elle ne respectait pas les principes
fondamentaux de la Charte des Nations
Unies qui ont demandé de le faire et on
demandait de cesser son agression et de
retirer immédiatement complètement et
inconditionnellement c'est trop ça n'est
donc pas un terrain sur lequel la Russie
progresse
cet isolement était également évident
quelques jours plus tard le 27 février
aux Nations Unies à Genève au Conseil
des droits de l'homme c'est la session
ministérielle du cancer des droits de
l'homme avec d'autres nous avons rappelé
notre refus de l'impunité russe en
l'Ukraine et donc au terme de cette
année je ne sais pas ce qui se passera
dans les heures ou les jours qui
viennent à barmouth ou sur d'autres
points du front au terme de cette année
la Russie ne peut pas crier victoire
elle a fait une erreur stratégique il
est patent et on peut le mesurer sur un
certain nombre de plans
pourtant oui monsieur le président de la
Russie
s'acharne elle ne donne aucun signe pour
le moment d'une disponibilité qui serait
la sienne à envisager une étape de
négociation et on voit aussi que elle
envoie
d'une façon assez inhabituelle et qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis le siècle le passé
c'est trop à l'assaut d'une façon qui ne
peut que provoquer des pertes humaines
en très grand nombre manifestement
l'ampleur de ces pertes n'est pas tout à
fait prise on compte par les dirigeants
russes et donc oui nous sommes à un
moment décisif il faut la Russie a
commencé de lancer une offensive qu'elle
va vraisemblablement vouloir poursuivre
avec la fin de l'hiver l'arrivée du
printemps de meilleure condition
météorologiques et donc c'est un moment
décisif et c'est ce moment qui doit être
celui où nous manifestons encore
davantage notre volonté d'aider
l'Ukraine à recouvrer sa souveraineté
nous n'avons pas attendu ce calcul
calendaire ou météorologiques pour
savoir qu'il fallait renforcer
intensifier notre aide à l'Ukraine
cet appel au renforcement se présente
date de l'automne dernier vous
souviendrez j'en avais parlé ici de la
décision prise par le Président de la
République encore amplifier depuis
de faire beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
vite pour que notre aide militaire
en complément de l'aide humanitaire
économique arrive à l'Ukraine et donc
oui nous devons le faire par un soutien
qui doit être massif et rapide
maintenant permettant d'aider lucrètes
non seulement à résister mais à être en
mesure si elle ne peut comme elle le
souhaite et quand elle le souhaitera et
quand elle le pourra de mener une
contre-offensive de changer le rapport
de force et de déjouer les calculs de
Moscou peut-être
d'amener Masco considéré qu'il lui faut
faire autrement mais si nous devons le
faire de façon massive et rapide et
c'est ce que nous faisons je crois que
vous voyez ce qui arrive en Ukraine il
faut le faire en répondant aux besoins
de l'Ukraine et quels sont les besoins
exprimés par le président zzki par
Monsieur resticov par le président de la
radar que vous avez sans doute reçu ce
sont aujourd'hui des besoins en munition
en moyen de défense antiérienne et en
maintenant c'est ce que les matériels
sont utilisés à très haute intensité
s'use vite et ont besoin d'être maintenu
en condition voilà ce que l'Ukraine
demande en ce moment vous connaissez le
débat sur les chats le jour il faudra
mener une offensive un jour peut-être
les avions mais les besoins de l'Ukraine
tels que les militaires Ukrainiens tels
que les responsables politiques
Ukrainiens nous expriment ce sont ces
catégories et ce sont celles-ci que nous
livrons
pourquoi et dont nous l'Ukraine je
voudrais
citer le président de la République
d'abord parce que c'est le chef de
l'État et le chef des armées mais aussi
parce qu'il y a eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur ces sujets récemment à
plusieurs reprises lors de la conférence
de sécurité à Munich par exemple ou dans
d'autres déplacements et il insiste
toujours je veux le faire après lui sur
le fait que cette guerre n'est pas une
guerre européenne n'est pas une guerre
européenne n'est pas une guerre qui
concernerait uniquement le continent
européen ou furtury uniquement
l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens bien sûr ça
concerne au premier chef des Ukrainiens
dont dans le sort est en jeu et même
l'Ukraine sur lequel pèse une menace
existentielle mais il est important de
se souvenir que si nous agissons c'est
bien sûr pour défendre un pays qui est
attaqué agressé sans aucune raison
sans aucune provocation sans aucune
justification donc une sorte et donc il
y a le droit légitime de se défendre
l'article 51 de la Charte des Nations
Unies mais c'est au-delà de ça parce que
l'agression russe est une agression
contre les principes fondamentaux de
l'achat des Nations Unies et croyez moi
si cette agression était récompensée et
bien s'en serait fini de la paix et de
la stabilité partout dans le monde ce
qui se produit là se produirait ailleurs
c'est une chose que nous devons répéter
non seulement n'être conscient mais
répété certains nombre de partenaires
qui n'en sont pas conscients autant que
nous cela les concerne autant que ça
concerne le continent européen pour
cette raison ils sont de même exposés si
les agressions sont récompensées et donc
voilà pourquoi mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le Président nous
devons mettre en échec
cette agression nous ne cherchant pas à
défaire la réussite nous cherchons à
défaire l'agression russe à vaincre
l'agression russe elle est seule
responsable de cette situation
ces principes du droit international
évidemment ne s'applique pas seulement
en
Ukraine vous avez évoqué nombre de
situations difficiles et nous entendons
les faire respecter partout
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire et
au-delà du cercle des partenaires
européens en Inde la semaine dernière je
dis vendredi puisque se réunissait en
Inde à New Delhi le G20 ministériel au
niveau ministre des Affaires étrangères
et c'est sur cette base parce que la
composition du G20 nous oblige à
réfléchir à ce que nous avons en commun
c'est sur cette base sur les bases de
ces principes partagées que nous
pourrons rétablir l'unité de la
communauté internationale réduire les
divisions ou les désaccords continuer de
faire prévaloir le droit sur la force
continuer d'isoler la Russie et c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs au-delà
de ce que nous faisons dans ces dans ces
grandes rendez-vous internationaux nous
sommes toujours actifs toujours
mobilisés pour que le système
multilatéral se réforme pour le rendre
plus efficace et plus représentatif il
ne l'est que partiellement c'est l'un
des combats de la France depuis plus de
20 ans que de viser une réforme de ce
système multilatéral nous le ferons
encore au mois de juin prochain j'y
reviendrai
vous avez évoqué le Proche-Orient et le
Moyen-Orient monsieur le Président je me
suis rendu dans le golf en Arabie
Saoudite et aux Émirats arabes unis et
j'ai retournerai dans les mois qui
viennent pour y renforcer nos
partenariats pour défendre nos positions
pour y faire valoir nos points de vue
sur la guerre russe en Ukraine et
au-delà et au-delà puisque une bonne
partie de nos entretiens ont été
consacrés à la menace grandissante que
pose le régime iranien
avec un certain nombre de sujets
tous complexes vous avez évoqué les
principaux monsieur Président c'est
d'abord le mouvement de protestation qui
a commencé au mois de septembre qui sans
doute se manifeste différemment
aujourd'hui le nombre de manifestations
ABC parce que la répression a été forte
pour ne pas dire terrible des dizaines
sans doute de milliers d'arrestations et
500 morts quoi qu'on ne connaissent pas
le chiffre exact des morts et vous avez
vu par ailleurs toutes les
interrogations que ce site les malaises
je devrais dire les empoisonnements dans
un certain nombre d'écoles de jeunes
filles
le peuple iranien a
exprimé ses revendications
revendications légitimes à nos yeux
à sa liberté
à l'égalité dignité de la personne
humaine et si la répression a fait que
les manifestations sont moins visibles
aujourd'hui
je suis comme vous persuadez que il y a
une un décrochage une perte de confiance
entre le régime et son peuple en tout
cas entre le régime et la jeunesse
iranienne
nous avons
pris un certain nombre de sanctions là
aussi contre les responsables de la
répression
le régime de sanctions est européen je
le rappelle nous avons adopté cinq
trains de sanction qui vise les
responsables de la répression en
complément des fabricants de drones qui
aident la Russie comme maître des crimes
en Ukraine et à ce jour ce sont presque
30 entités une centaine d'individus qui
sont concernés dont certains membres du
gouvernement iraniens il y a eu deux
ministres sanctionnés dans le dernier
train de sanctions adoptées à la fin du
mois dernier et des branches
particulièrement impliquées du corps des
Gardiens de la Révolution
aujourd'hui même l'Union européenne
vient
de sanctionner une douzaine de personnes
dans un certain nombre de pays dont
l'Iran qui sont responsables de
violation des droits des femmes
lesquelles font partie des droits de
l'homme faut-il le rappeler par ailleurs
nous avons réussi à obtenir que les
Nations Unies déclenchent une mission
d'établissement des faits pour faire la
lumière sur les événements mieux que par
le sol récit des officiels iraniens et
donc recueillir des éléments de preuves
de façon impartiale et indépendante je
ne dirais pas que l'Iran a beaucoup
apprécié
succès diplomatique qui a été la
création de la mission d'établissement
des faits il est important que la
mission puisse enquêter comme elle le
fait son premier rapport sera un rapport
oral rendu prochainement au mois de juin
avant un rapport complet au mois de mars
prochain
les Nations Unies Commission des droits
de l'homme
il se trouve qu'au Conseil de sécurité
certains membres permanents
usent ou abusent de leurs droits de veto
la Russie au premier chef elle l'a fait
au mois de mars dernier
au-delà de ce sujet
au sein de la Commission des droits de
l'homme non
au Conseil de sécurité il y a un système
de veto pas au sein de la commission
elle a protesté par différents
moyens et l'Iran de même
il y a une autre dimension aux
difficultés que posent l'Iran à la
communauté internationale vous l'avez
évoqué aussi monsieur le Président et
c'est le grave très grave sujet de la
menace nucléaire c'est aujourd'hui la
principale menace
pourtant je voudrais signaler à la
commission que le directeur général de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique a pu un certain nombre
démarches l'ont permis se rendre à
Téhéran en fin de semaine dernière être
reçu par les autorités iraniennes avoir
accès à un certain nombre
d'installations également et
à recueilli un certain nombre
d'engagements de la part de l'Iran
ces engagements ce sont des promesses et
donc il faudra voir évidemment si ces
promesses sont suivis de mesure
concrètes et rapidement et si la
transparence promise
sera au rendez-vous parce que c'est seul
ce type de mesure et cette transparence
qui permettront de sortir de ce chemin
d'escalade que suit les rangs depuis
quelques mois
nous rappellerons à ce pays ces
obligations car il s'agit bien
d'obligation demain à l'agence de Vienne
où se réunit le Conseil des gouverneurs
de la
troisième dimension à la crise iranienne
la capacité de déstabilisation
de ce pays et en effet la menace
iranienne elle prend également la forme
d'une série d'actions déstabilisatrices
dans la région je pense notamment à la
prolifération de missiles
aux livraison de drones à la Russie je
l'évoquais mais à la prolifération de
missiles dans la région et aux livraison
d'armes dans la région transfert d'un
moment qui menace la stabilité de la
région un certain nombre de pays du
Golfe en particulier et ont déjà été
l'objet d'attaque de missiles je parle
notamment des émirats je me suis rendu à
quelques semaines menace aussi pour le
trafic maritime international la zone
voyant passer une très importante
proportion du trafic maritime
international dans nos économies
dépendent et on a vu en particulier
c'est toute dernière semaine je parle là
de l'année 2023 avec deux saisies et de
saisie que nous avons choisi de rendre
public qui ont été effectués l'une par
les forces françaises l'autre par les
forces britanniques de dizaines de
tonnes d'armement iraniens
y compris pas seulement de la chnikov ou
de mitraillette y compris de missiles
antichard provenant d'Iran et à
destination des rebelles outils au Yémen
et ceci quand bien même la trêve
informelle au Yémen tient depuis
plusieurs mois
face
toutes ces menaces et je n'en évoque que
quelques-unes la France doit opposer une
détermination ferme
mais conformes à ses valeurs c'est à
dire une réponse de solidarité
ça consiste à soutenir d'abord nos
partenaires qui sont les plus
directement touchés par ces menaces mais
ça consiste aussi à venir en aide aux
populations quand elles en ont besoin
vous parliez de la tournée dans quelques
pays d'Afrique fait la semaine dernière
par le Président de la République et
notamment de son action en République
démocratique du Congo je veux rappeler
qu'il a
ses propos en témoignent
soutenus de façon tout à fait directe et
classique
la stabilité de la RDC et rappeler que
nous restions au côté de la RDC il a
plaidé fortement pour la relance du
processus de paix avec un certain nombre
de
processus celui de Luanda
paraît peut-être le plus prometteur
celui Nairobi aussi notre soutien et
nous sommes en contact fréquent avec
les dirigeants et homologues gagnant
pour ce qui me concerne puisque le Kenya
a déployé une force
près de près de Goma
nous soutenons aussi la mise en place
dans ces selfie et le retrait et la
demande de retrait du M23 qui est un
mouvement soutenu par le Rwanda a été au
cœur de tous les entretiens du président
de la République donc je pense que la
ligne de la France sur ce point est
clair ça n'empêche pas la solidarité je
le disais et ces manifesté y compris
lors de cette visite monsieur le
Président puisque la France a annoncé
une aide humanitaire de 34 millions
d'euros en complément de l'aide
européenne de 45 ou peut-être 47 je ne
sais plus un million d'euros et de plus
nous avons
à la RDC bien sûr oui et de plus le
président était en République
démocratique du Congo je ne crois pas
qu'il soit allé au Ronda donc sa
dernière étape était l'air il aurait pu
y aller sans doute faut-il y aller et
retourner et retourner la secrétaire
d'État que vous avez auditionné à
quelques semaines monsieur président
était allé au nom de la France également
nous avons également annoncé la mise en
place d'un pont hum anitaire avec Goma
qui est l'objet d'une pression de la
part des forces du mouvement M23
solidarité aussi avec la Turquie et la
Syrie
de pays touchés par
double séisme et avec les répliques qui
ont suivi quant également fait beaucoup
de dégâts la France a répondu présent
dès le premier jour
nous avons envoyé des le dimanche donc
dès le jour du séisme la première
secousse des sauveteurs et des équipes
cinéphiles du matériel en Turquie nous
en avons déployé d'autres ensuite puis
déployer un hôpital de campagne équipé
et approvisionner permettant de traiter
une centaine de patients simultanément
nous avons aussi aidé les populations
syriennes
et quelques difficultés que présente
l'accès à la série puisqu'il a fallu
plusieurs jours pour que les autorités
syriennes acceptent d'ouvrir un deuxième
puis un troisième point de passage pour
que l'aide arrive nous avons pu aider
les populations syriennes dans le nord
de la Syrie lorsqu'elles étaient
affectées par le séisme et débloqué pour
cela près de 20 millions d'euros tout en
nous assurant que l'aide ne bénéficie
pas au régime mais parviennent
directement aux populations et sans
possibilité de détournement et ceci en
passant par le canal des Nations Unies
et par le canal d'ONG de confiance sur
place
si nous avons pu agir vite et avec des
moyens conséquents je parlais de du
volume d'aide pour la Syrie de suivi de
l'aide d'un RDC c'est aussi mesdames et
messieurs les députés parce que vous
avez doté mon ministère de moyens
d'action ambitieux et innovant dans le
cadre de la loi de finance pour 2023 la
provision pour crise nous notamment
semaine après semaine depuis quelques
temps avait été fortement augmenté elle
avait pratiquement été multipliée par 10
vous en souvenez sage prudence et sage
précaution puisque c'est elle qui nous
permet de mobiliser son délai des moyens
importants la France aujourd'hui est
vraiment revenue parmi les grandes
puissances de l'humanitaire et peut
concrètement rapidement et auteur de
plusieurs dizaines de millions et des
ceux qui en ont besoin
au-delà de l'urgence il faut aussi dans
le cadre de cette politique de
solidarité mener des actions de long
terme et nouer des partenariats de long
terme et donc nous redoublons d'efforts
du G20 dont je parlais avec le sommet
qui viendra en septembre à la cop27
bientôt à la COP 28 ou à la COP15 nous
redoublons d'efforts pour construire des
réponses collectives au grand
déséquilibre globaux pour répondre d'une
façon plus structurelle à ses désordres
pour endiguer le risque d'une
fragmentation du monde selon
l'expression devenue classique et je
veux rappeler notamment dans le cadre de
ce de cette vue de long terme
l'importance de l'enjeu écologique
si le président de la République s'est
rendu au Gabon monsieur le Président
c'est parce que s'y tenez dans cette
zone où le Gabon a une action plus
avancée peut-être que celle de ces de
ses voisins nous y tenions le premier
One forest Summit à Libreville sur
initiative française avec l'objectif de
parvenir pendant qu'il est temps un
accord juste permettant de
de concilier la protection de la forêt
tropicale qui sont des espaces cruciaux
pour notre environnement et pour le
climat avec les puits de carbone non
reproductibles et
conciliation aussi avec les enjeux de
développement si c'est un développement
raisonné maîtrisé les pays concernés en
ont besoin
leur population aussi
autre action de long terme je l'évoque
rapidement mais bien sûr y revenir
et j'en disais un mot tout au début de
cette introduction
l'enjeu de conjurer les risques d'une
nouvelle
[Musique]
fragmentation Nord-Sud on connaît les
critiques ou les observations d'un
certain nombre de pays du Sud je dis du
Sud en m'attachant à mettre des
guillemets car je crois qu'il y a rien
de plus faux que de parler du Sud global
il y a beaucoup de Sud la Chine se
décrirait peut-être dans les pays du Sud
global c'est aujourd'hui la première
puissance
commerciale au monde économique et
commercial dont je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
fasse partie du Sud et donc beaucoup de
situations différentes il faut les
traiter chacune d'entre elles
mais nous voulons dans le cadre de la
rénovation du multilatéralisme efficace
que nous appelons de nos vœux nous
voulons aussi répondre à un certain
nombre de leurs besoins lorsqu'ils sont
justifiés comme c'est le cas pour
notamment la finance climat et donc
c'est acharmel chèque à la COP 27 qui
est venu l'idée qu'après une autre
ampleur maintenant que de réunir à Paris
un sommet international sur les
financements internationaux les 22 et 23
juin j'ai pu transmettre
le 24 février au Secrétaire général des
Nations unies l'invitation que lui
adressée le président de la République
française à venir
à ce sommet et il a accepté donc nous
accueillons au sommet international de
façon
à sceller un nouveau pacte financier
global il y aura aussi des institutions
financières internationales et nos
partenaires des pays du monde parce
qu'il est indispensable de renforcer
l'accès au financement internationaux
des pays en développement en particulier
des pays les plus vulnérables et en
particulier pour répondre à leurs
besoins de transition écologique et
énergétique il faudrait associer
également
des partenaires privés
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce que
je viens d'évoquer avec vous
c'est vous le voyez la ligne d'action de
fond de la France qui consiste à faire
prévaloir des principes qui permettent
de travailler à l'unité contre les
tentatives de division et en même temps
de refonder un certain nombre de
partenariats pour les rénover et leur
permettre nous permettre de faire face
aux défis d'aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont
été renouvelés et à ceux que nous voyons
prendre pour demain
c'est précisément le sens de notre
action sur le continent africain
le président de la République s'est
exprimé lundi 27 février pour fixer le
cap et un cap qui doit nous faire sortir
des logiques
passailliste de compétition ou du
prétendu précarité qui a depuis
longtemps disparu et c'est dans cet
esprit que oui nous renouvelons les
modalités de notre partenariat militaire
avec un certain nombre de pays africains
ce sera dorénavant moins de soldats
français le président de la indiquée
dans ce qu'on discours du mois de
novembre sur des bases qui seront des
bases kogérées avec les partenaires
africains françaises dans un pays
africain et avec une action que nous
voulons développer davantage
qu'aujourd'hui en matière de formation
et d'équipements donc être à leur côté
mais non pas
au premier rang plutôt en second rang
et nous devons continuer d'investir dans
ces pays et dans ce continent parce que
nous savons que l'Afrique sera l'un des
grands foyers de croissance dans les
décennies qui viennent la croissance
mondiale viendra largement du continent
africain et nous devons donc hier au
présent d'une façon différente en
cherchant des partenariats équilibrés en
faisant valoir nos atouts sans arrogance
comme l'ont dit avec peut-être plus
d'humilité qu'il fut un temps qu'il fut
un temps lointain mais nous devons oui
assumer ce que nous sommes faire valoir
et nos valeurs et nos atouts et nos
intérêts et nous avons des atouts en
Afrique nous liens humains nos diaspora
nos entreprises nos capacités de
recherche que nous faisons en
partenariat dans le domaine de la santé
donc nous devons continuer dans cette
voie c'est en particulier ce qui a été
le thème de la visite du président de la
République en Angola en fin de semaine
dernière lorsqu'il s'est engagé aux
côtés d'entrepreneurs agricoles
africains et français sur le continent
il y a de belles perspectives de
coopération et donc vous le voyez
avec le continent l'idée de sortir d'une
logique d'aide et de passer à une
logique d'investissement solidaire en
mettant
en oeuvre davantage de projets concrets
et je dirais même parfois de projets
visibles permettant de répondre aux
attentes de la jeunesse et de la société
civile j'étais frappée par exemple mais
c'est une expérience parmi tant et tant
d'autres lorsque je me suis rendu en
Côte d'Ivoire en fin d'année dernière
j'ai tenu aller non seulement dans les
quartiers de la présidence de la
République ou des ministères mais dans
un quartier plus populaire qui est
Yopougon qui n'est pas tout à fait un
quartier gouvernemental
loin sans faut rencontrer
rencontrer un certain nombre de jeunes
de de tout métier de toutes origines
certains engagés dans les droits des
femmes d'autres travaux sur
l'agriculture d'autres ayant monté des
start-ups et j'étais frappée de voir que
nous savons mal aidé ces jeunes qui sont
extrêmement bien formés extrêmement
positifs ambitieux et
regardons l'avenir avec confiance
parce que les projets qui sont leurs
projets sont parfois des projets d'une
taille trop grande pour nos instruments
d'ambassades et trop petit pour ceux de
l'AFD et donc nous avons décidé de faire
un certain nombre de choses et avec
l'accord du président de la République
nous avons créé de nouveau dispositifs
j'ai fait créer un fond
qui est doté de 40 millions d'euros pour
que nous ambassadeurs puissent mener
directement sur le continent des projets
et des projets qui font du sens pour
tous ces publics cibles et deuxième
action nous avons également créé
oui de l'ambassadeur qui est responsable
et qui rencontre un ministre lequel on
rencontre au-dessus mais
l'instruction se fera par l'ambassade et
je crois qu'on est au plus près du
terrain plus efficace sur un certain
nombre de réponses possibles à ces
actions que ces jeunes lancent ont lancé
et mériteraient de lancer avec notre
présence partenaire alors que tu es
deuxième action nous avons également
créé au sein de mon ministère un fond de
20 millions d'euros cette fois pour que
nos instituts français à l'étranger puis
soutenir les industries culturelles et
créatives elles sont particulièrement
prometteuses en Afrique dans pas mal de
pays il s'agit aussi de
développer une plus grande intimité avec
la société civile au-delà des cercles
officiels
contenu de tout cela j'aurai l'occasion
de réunir très prochainement nos
ambassadeurs sur le continent africain
lors d'une visio-conférence pour ne pas
les obliger à se déplacer pour échanger
avec eux pour leur rappeler les les
grands axes de notre politique envers
l'Afrique tel que le président l'exposé
et les entendre témoignaient de leur
expérience et nous faire j'en suis sûr
un certain nombre de recommandations et
de proposition également donc voilà une
politique qui doit être plus qu'avant ou
encore plus qu'avant au contact de tout
ce contact des sociétés et pas des seuls
gouvernants même si je me dois de dire
monsieur le Président que ça n'est pas
la France qui désigne les dirigeants de
pays étrangers nous nous adressons
aux responsables que nous avons et nous
nous adressons aussi comme toujours mais
en voulant le faire encore plus aux
artistes aux sportifs aux jeunes aux
chercheurs aux entrepreneurs au diaspora
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
mange ce qu'il n'y a
aucune fatalité aucune fatalité à voir
les incompréhensions s'installer on sait
ce qu'il est créé on sait encore plus
qui enjo et par quels moyens je vous en
parlais la prochaine fois mais vous
savez à quel pays je fais référence et
au moyen qui sont utilisés un dernier
mot mesdames et messieurs les députés
parce que je vous sais attentif non
seulement au chronomètre qui passe mais
aux évolutions en cours au sein de mon
ministère et je voudrais terminer en
évoquant très brièvement les états
généraux de la diplomatie
mais je
le fais de toute façon
j'allais justement vous complémenter
donc ça permet que ce spontané non pas
appelé par le président de ces vœux
notre rapporteur général qui est
l'ambassadeur Jérôme Bonafont
à achevé ses travaux et ce de son équipe
il me remettra bientôt son rapport
rapport qui a été réalisé dans les temps
vraiment en quelques mois et qui s'est
appuyé sur un travail qui est
[Musique]
absolument inédit pour notre ministère
de consultation de l'ensemble des agents
de ceux qui le souhaitaient quel que
soit leur statuts quel que soit leur
situation quel que soit le lieu
géographique de leur travail au total
nous avons pu impliquer près de 5000
agents je veux citer le chiffre parce
que ce ministère qui est le plus beau
d'entre tous évidemment est un petit
ministère par le nombre de ces agents
puisque il a aujourd'hui 13500 agents
donc parvenir à toucher plus d'un tiers
je crois que ça a été un remarquable
travail de la part de l'équipe du
rapporteur et de l'équipe des États
généraux
et je remercie toute me réjouissant de
leur contribution je remercie tous les
parlementaires qui nous ont apporté
aussi leurs idées et leurs observations
nous avons tenu compte autant que faire
ce pouvait et je vous mets au premier
rang monsieur le Président puisque votre
contribution personnelle a été réelle et
je dirais même forte ou très forte
et moi-même je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
adviendra mais je veux préciser en vous
disant que ce rapport que j'ai reçu et
commencer non officiellement encore mais
commencez de regarder de façon précise
nourrira mes échanges avec le président
de la République
et la première ministre
et je serai ensuite à l'écoute de leurs
décisions parce que je crois que ce
rapport est le travail qui qui sont
suivra nous permettra de
d'avoir la base pour la transformation
nécessaire du Quai d'Orsay pour que ce
ministère soit à même de faire face aux
grands défis notre époque il peut mieux
accomplir sa mission d'ouverture dans
d'autres pays sur le monde en étant
aussi un mystère de l'innovation c'est
une dimension qu'il faut pousser il peut
être le ministère d'une expertise
précise qui articule les savoirs dit
traditionnels sans la négociation la
connaissance des langues l'expérience du
métier tout simplement la connaissance
des sociétés avec des savoirs nouveaux
en matière de numérique de communication
un certain nombre de sujets techniques
et les négociations sur la préservation
de la haute mer bibi Angie qui viennent
de se conclure avec succès à New York
doivent beaucoup au ministre de la mère
kervé Berville mais également beaucoup
aux équipes de mon ministère qui l'ont
entouré la gentillesse de me le rappeler
tout à l'heure donc je me sens autorisée
à le rappeler croyez-moi le droit de la
mer et d'une chose particulièrement
complexe même pour des juristes de
talents
nous aurons d'autres champs investir qui
nécessitent eux-mêmes des compétences
précises le climat la santé l'énergie
l'intelligence artificielle et sans
doute tant d'autres à venir et c'est ce
chantier de transformation qui
permettent au mystère de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères d'être au centre de
l'État et de son action internationale
dans le monde que je veux réussir c'est
un beau programme et ce sera vous vous
en doutez ma priorité à la tête de ce
ministère merci monsieur le Président il
me reste beaucoup de sujets certainement
mais j'ai je crois évoqué la plupart
d'entre de ce que vous aviez vous-même
évoqué c'est moi qui vous remercie
madame la ministre de ce voyage
interplanétaire extrêmement
substantielle et maintenant ce sont les
groupes qui vont vous poser des
questions
qu'ils estiment nécessaire de vous poser
et aujourd'hui ce sont les socialistes
qui ouvrent le bal c'est à dire Monsieur
David merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre
je tiens au nom des députés de mon
groupe revenir sur la récente tournée du
chef de l'État
dans plusieurs pays africains
visitant le Centre Afrique le Gabon le
Congo la République démocratique du
Congo il n'a pu se départir de son
habituel arrogance et à froissé nombre
de ses interlocuteurs
c'est la presse qui le dit c'est
au moment où l'influence de la de la
France dans de nombreux pays africains
et contestés au moment où le soutien de
certains dirigeants peu démocratiques
est interrogée au moment où
l'exploitation non éthique de certaines
ressources naturelles par des grands
groupes multinationaux apparaît en
décalage avec les grands enjeux
environnementaux
ces déplacements manifestement mal
préparés suscite une indignation
compréhensible
notre commission travaille sur ces
questions avance des propositions
souvent transportizon et je trouve que
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment entendu
et associés par votre ministère et
encore moins par l'Élysée
je souhaite donc que les intentions
présidentielles souvent changeantes
alors que la diplomatie nécessite
constance et respect soient précisé
après cette question d'actualité je
prendrai quelques instants également
pour vous interroger sur un sujet qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur en tant
que président du groupe d'amitié France
Birmanie depuis le coup d'État militaire
les exactions se poursuivent s'aggravent
même loin de l'attention médiatique et
l'astre souvent loin de la tension
diplomatique
aussi je souhaiterais que la diplomatie
française si elle le peut puisse
s'engager sur une amplification de
l'aide d'humanitaire en faveur des
populations civiles durement touchées
dans le pays et aux frontières pour
celles et ceux qui fuient et sur une
éventuelle initiative de la France au
Conseil de sécurité pour que ce soit
examiner la possibilité de déférer un
certain nombre de crimes commis par la
junte au Tribunal pénal international
également sur une reconnaissance à terme
du gouvernement en exil merci je vous
remercie monsieur député madame la
ministre de deux questions très
importantes une et l'autre
vous avez en principe deux minutes et
demi
mais quand même je vous rappellerai
à l'ordre monsieur député monsieur
député David merci de vos questions de
questions importantes qui mériteraient
plus d'une minute pour vous répondre sur
la tournée du président de la République
en Afrique je regrette de ne pas vous
avoir convaincu lorsque je rappelais
quels sont les grands axes de l'action
de la France de l'action de la France et
j'ai pris le soin d'assortir ce propos
général de précision sur l'aide que nous
apportons où ce que nous allons faire
pour aider davantage un certain nombre
de forces vives dans ces pays je ne
ferai pas de commentaires sur la presse
elle en fait suffisamment et j'ai pour
habitude
depuis quelques dizaines d'années de
laisser la presse libre de ses jugements
et il lui arrive de se tromper comme
chacun d'entre nous
sur la Birmanie
vous le savez mais je le répète il y a
des sanctions qui visent les la jantes
et nous avons
à l'occasion du deuxième anniversaire
hélas du coup d'État de février 2021
renforcer notre pression diplomatique
saisie le Conseil de sécurité dans la
perspective de cette
échéance et pour la première fois la fin
de l'année dernière une résolution a pu
être adaptée qui concerne la Roumanie la
Birmanie pardonnez-moi par ailleurs
l'action diplomatique de la France est
dans certains nombre de ses partenaires
se poursuit
pour ceux qui concerne notre pays mais
je crois qu'il faut rappeler que la
France n'est pas seule à agir en ce sens
j'ai eu l'occasion de parler il y a un
peu plus de huit jours seulement à mon
homologue ministre des Affaires
étrangères de l'Indonésie qui se trouve
être en présidence de l'azéanne laquelle
en temps jouer un rôle pour amener la
jante le burratel nous le verrons mais
pour amener la jante à
une transition un meilleur rythme
c'était l'objet principal de mon
entretien je l'ai revu par ailleurs au
G20 mais ça c'était un entretien que
nous avons eu ailleurs et qui a été très
largement centrée sur ce sujet
vous avez je sais pas si vous avez
comblé Monsieur David mais vous avez
comblé le président en tenant dans un
délai extraordinairement
limité pour maintenant le tour est à
horizon c'est Monsieur le Député de la
Haute-Garonne monsieur portarieux qui va
vous parler vous interrogez merci
monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
madame la ministre le rôle du procureur
de la Cour pénale internationale qui
enquête depuis une bonne année sur les
crimes commisanniques et on ne peut
d'ailleurs que souhaiter l'ouverture
prochaine d'un bureau pour se procureur
pour la Cour pénale internationale à
Kiev mais je souhaite revenir sur un
événement lié à ces questions de de
droit international un événement qui est
passé assez inaperçu la semaine dernière
la chef du jeune parquet européen
anti-froid qui roumaine elle s'appelle
Laura caudrutacovei a souhaité
s'attaquer aux violations des sanctions
contre la Russie des sanctions
prononcées contre la Russie notamment
par l'Union européenne et qui
semble-t-il ne sont absolument pas
respectés la magistrate dispose d'un
mondonbre de procureurs spécialisés
qu'elle pourrait parfaitement mobiliser
pour cibler les individus les
entreprises les organisations
criminelles qui contournent ces
différentes sanctions économiques
imposées à la Russie par l'Union
européenne mais il y a au moins une
condition à remplir c'est que les 22
États qui participent à ce parquet
européen lui donne un mandat alors ne
croyez-vous pas madame la ministre que
la France pourrait prendre cette
initiative
merci Monsieur président merci monsieur
le député
nous aidons et soutenons le travail qui
est fait par la Cour pénale
internationale notamment par le
procureur général Karim Kahn vous avez
noté je pense avec intérêt qui s'était
déplacé tout récemment à Kiev et avait
été bien reçu par les autorités de ce
pays ce qui augure d'une meilleure
coopération entre la CPI et l'Ukraine
coopération qui nous paraît
indispensable pour pouvoir lutter
efficacement contre l'impunité
par ailleurs vous le savez mais je le
rappelle il y a des réflexions en cours
sur les moyens
en complément du travail de la justice
ukrainienne et en complément du travail
de la CPI
instant se compétente et qui a été saisi
par 43 États dont la totalité des États
européens et dans la France en
complément de tout ça et de l'aide que
nous apportons tant à la justice
ukrainienne que la Cour pénale
internationale il y a des réflexions
cours auxquelles nous participons sur la
possibilité de compléter le dispositif
international de façon à permettre de
sanctionner le crime d'agression
d'agression dans la Russie est
responsable pour ce qui est du
contournement
je regarderai plus en détail ce qu'il en
est de ce point particulier dont je
n'étais pas informé mais j'étais en
déplacement la semaine dernière
peut-être ceci explique-t-il cela la
question du contournement des sanctions
fait partie des priorités de l'Union
européenne et donc des priorités de la
France notamment quand d'autres pays
sont utilisés pour contourner les
sanctions mais les sanctions je le
rappelle
ne sont
applicable que au pays qui les ont
décidé un pays qui n'a pas par exemple
des pieds qui ne sont pas
des pays membres de l'Union européenne
ou d'autres pays ayant pris des
sanctions je parle Japon Suisse Canada
Etats-Unis ne sont pas tenus par nos
sanctions donc c'est une voie de
contournement
qui
existent sans qu'on puisse la qualifier
de contournement pour ce qui est du
contournement donc des irrégularités qui
seraient commises je regarderai je vous
ferai réponse puisque ce sont en
principe les autorités nationales on
commence par elle qui sont compétentes
pour sanctionner ce qui serait en
contournement avéré dans un pays qui
applique les sanctions d'édits sanctions
merci merci madame la ministre monsieur
Aurélien taché pour le groupe écologiste
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre donc profitez de votre
présence pour évoquer plusieurs sujets
évidemment il y a la question de
l'Afrique mais je crois que je vous ai
exprimé mon opinion tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle et vous êtes revenu sur un
certain nombre de points d'ailleurs je
vous en remercie parce que ça permet
d'avoir un éclairage un petit peu plus
important notamment sur la position de
la France sur l'attitude du Rwanda au
Kivu vous avez été assez clair plus
clair que le Président de la République
je crois d'ailleurs mais c'est c'est
intéressant
j'ajouterai juste un point sur cette
question de l'Afrique que je n'ai pas
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est le sujet du
Sénégal qui préoccupe je crois certains
d'entre nous au sein de cette commission
vous nous avez demandé de ratifier un
projet de loi sur une convention
d'extradition il a peu de temps
en la situation au Sénégal semble sur le
plan démocratique s'empirer des qui sont
arrêtés des opposants politiques sont
traînés en justice Macky Sall le
président Macky Sall ne devrait pas
pouvoir se représenter pour un troisième
mandat la France
tiendra-t-elle cette position quoi qu'il
en coûte si j'ose dire sera telle
capable de dire à Macky Sall au moment
venu qu'effectivement
s'il devait se représenter une troisième
fois
ça ne pourrait pas être dans
l'indifférence
vis-à-vis des relations avec la France
c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
demander sur l'Afrique j'aimerais vous
parler d'un autre sujet qui est celui de
la situation en Turquie vous avez
rappelé les événements terribles qui
viennent finalement de ce de ce passé en
Turquie
sur le plan politique nous avons un
président Erdogan qui est élu depuis
presque 20 ans des relations
franco-turques qui ont été marquées par
des successions de crise politique et
diplomatique malgré une histoire
ancienne puisque la Sublime Porte
accueillait les diplomates français
envoyés par François 1er dès le 16e
siècle
mais sans remonter aussi loin peut-être
que finalement si on se replonge dans
une époque plus contemporaine il y a 10
ou 15 ans il y a eu un certain nombre de
ratés avec ce pays je pense au moment où
Nicolas Sarkozy a d'autorité fermée les
négociations pour une éventuelle entrée
dans l'Union européenne je crois que ça
a contribué grandement à amener la
Turquie vers un certain nombre de pays
avec lesquels aujourd'hui nous ne
partageons que peu de valeur je crois
que ces motivations là étaient pour
certaines d'entre elles peu louables et
notamment fondée sur un motivation
identitaire qui fait qu'on aurait une
Europe qui ne pourrait être que
judéo-chrétienne dans 70 jours il y aura
des élections présidentielles
Erdogan est donné perdants dans toutes
les dans tous les sondages d'opinion
qu'est-ce que vous envisagez comme
avenir pour les relations francs en
couture avec cette nouvelle page qui va
s'écrire merci Madame la Michou je vous
remercie madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le député tâcher sur le Sénégal
vous me rendez perplexe parce que tout à
la fois j'avais compris de vos
interventions tout à l'heure et de vos
positions
générales que vous étiez pour le
renouvellement de nos relations avec
l'Afrique sur de nouvelles bases comme
nous employons à le faire et dans le
même temps vous vous inquiétez de notre
absence de capacité dictée son
comportement un pays je crois qu'il faut
encore et toujours rappeler que on ne
s'ingère pas dans la politique ni de ce
pays ni d'autres et ce dont nous parlons
en revanche avec tous y compris avec le
Sénégal je vous le confirme très
volontiers c'est des questions qui nous
tiennent à cœur qui auraient à l'état de
droit au droit de l'homme et dans l'État
de droit je pense que vous pouvez
inclure le respect de la Constitution
mais en tout cas je vais vous dire que
nous ne décidons pas pour autrui sur la
Turquie
là aussi sans vouloir vous reprendre je
ne crois pas que ce soit un président
français qui est décédé seul en tout cas
vous avez dit seul des positions de
l'Union européenne puisque les
négociations si elles ont été suspendues
ou interrompus ne l'ont pas été à
l'initiative de la France mais après une
série de difficultés
avec un pays qui avait beaucoup de mal à
faire progresser ses négociations et
surtout beaucoup de mal à considérer ce
que sont les valeurs de l'Union
européenne qu'elle aspire ré pourtant
disait-elle à rejoindre ce détail
historique est en rappelé nous serons
attentifs en Turquie comme ailleurs
au respect des bonnes règles des
élections n'a pas été
modifié par le séisme certains
s'interrogeaient là-dessus c'est plutôt
bon signe pourra-t-on estimer ou pas dit
certains parce que des conditions de
déroulement du scrutin ne sont pas
parfaites dans tout le pays
en tout cas nous serons attentifs à ce
que autant que faire se peut le scrutin
se déroule dans de bonnes conditions et
parallèlement nous avons un dialogue
avec la Russie j'ai vu avec la Turquie
décidément je fatigue trop de voyages je
voyais mon collègue et bon collègue
turc l'autre jour au G20 nous ne sommes
pas d'accord surtout pour autant nous
avons aussi à saluer à encourager
dirais-je le rôle positif que je voulais
Turquie par exemple dans l'accord sur la
mer Noire qui permet l'exportation de
grains de céréales et d'engrais avec la
nécessité pour autant de lui rappeler en
effet la règle de droit et m'est arrivé
de devoir appeler mon homologue je l'ai
fait au moins deux reprises sur la
préoccupation qui était la nôtre lorsque
la Turquie bombardée en dehors de ces
frontières
des populations kurdes
si merci
la négociation de la Turquie c'était le
retent où là la Cedeo la cape se
présentait comme une variante
méridionale de la Cedeo là pour la
gauche démocratique démocrate et
républicaine monsieur Lecoq merci
monsieur le président
je voudrais vous interroger sur la
Palestine le président de la fée vous
l'avez pas répondu parce que j'avais
transmis à votre cabinet le thème sur
lequel j'allais vous interroger et donc
je pense que vous aviez gardé la réponse
pour moi c'est très sympathique la
situation actuelle découle de l'inaction
de la communauté internationale qui n'a
jamais été
au-delà des condamnations diplomatiques
stériles jamais la colonisation
l'apartheid et le nettoyage ethnique en
cours n'ont été combattus par le Conseil
de sécurité des Nations unies cette
inaction décomplexée les racistes et les
suprématistes israéliens au pouvoir dont
la politique a déjà tué plus de 65
Palestiniens a fait des centaines de
blessés depuis le 1er janvier et rien ne
les arrêtera de continuer tant qu'ils ne
seront pas sévèrement punis car les
choses continuent d'empirer en 6
Jordanie la région est désormais
formellement annexée par Israël et
gouverné par une administration civile
dans laquelle seuls les colons ont des
droits cette annexion était une ligne
rouge pour la communauté internationale
mais rien n'a été fait pour la condamner
une loi qui vient d'être votée qui
stipule d'ailleurs qu'une personne qui
tue un citoyen israélien doit être
condamné à la peine de mort un régime
d'apartheides se définit par un régime
ou un groupe de citoyens est supérieur
en droit à un autre au sein d'un même
État c'est exactement ce qui se passe
là-bas vous devez mesurer l'impact de
l'inaction des états entre guillemets à
midi d'Israël ou Sanguinet sur le droit
international l'impunité d'Israël est le
tombeau du droit international plutôt
que votre complicité avec ce criminel de
guerre de nombreuses actions concrètes
doivent être faites par la France même
unilatéralement reconnaître l'État de
Palestine accélérer l'enquête de la Cour
pénale internationale sur les crimes à
Gaza et faciliter la visite des
personnels de la cour sur place
sanctionner les élus Israéliens et les
organisations responsables de ces crimes
notamment en gelant leurs avoir mettre
fin au blocus de Gaza interdire
l'importation de bien et de services des
colonies et sanctionner les entreprises
du commerce avec les entreprises des
colonies se retirer du Conseil
d'associations Union européenne Israël
et exigée d'y mettre fin vous savez tout
à l'heure montrer qu'il y avait des
trains de sanctions imaginables avec des
pays qui ne respectent pas le droit
international vous avez parlé de l'Iran
vous avez parlé de la Russie et d'autres
et bien quel train de sanctions allez
vous mettre en place pour faire
respecter le droit international et pour
faire respecter les règles par Israël et
puis peut-être que la France pourrait
porter la notion de mission
d'établissement des faits sur les crimes
d'apartheid par la Cour parle la
commission de l'ONU sur les droits de
l'homme voilà merci monsieur le
Président j'avais deux sujets sur mais
je les poserai pas non non pas après
parce que je dois intervenir je vous
quitterai après parce que je dois
intervenir dans les musiques dans
quelques minutes vous
allez réussir au programme de Monsieur
Lecoq
dans le temps qui met un parti merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
député mon cabinet me cache en tout ne
m'avait pas dit que vous vouliez
m'interroger sur la situation au
Proche-Orient
remercie je leur remercie néanmoins je
vais faire de mon mieux pour vous
répondre avec peut-être des termes plus
modérés que ce que vous employez mais et
vous appartiennent nous sommes vous le
savez extrêmement préoccuper nous avons
pris un certain nombre de déclaration
officielle à ce titre par ce qui se
passe sur le terrain qui est une
dégradation continue
et les violences continuent la violence
engendre la violence nous le savons tous
donc nous avons appelé les uns et les
autres à d'autres comportements et je
dois observer en plus qu'il y a
évidemment un contraste assez saisissant
entre les violences quotidiennes qui
sont clairement à la hausse et les
promesses de ce que les accords
d'Abraham devaient apporter accord
conclu par Monsieur Netanyahu et
qu'elle reste attachée assez
imparfaitement accord qui est au
demeurant sont mais vous me comprenez
tout autant sont utiles parce qu'ils
permettent de faire baisser l'attention
tout en étant insuffisant évidemment
puisque ils sont construits autour de
du vide dans une question qui n'est pas
abordée qui est la question de fond la
question politique alors ne dites pas
que nous ne faisons rien
d'abord je dois rappeler à la commission
que je conseille de sécurité des Nations
unies à adopter
déclaration présidentielle
objet de
d'assez longue et délicate négociation
qui appelle à la fin des violences ça a
été fait dans la semaine du 20 février
c'était l'objet de beaucoup d'efforts de
nos de nous-mêmes et nos partenaires
mais je devrais les placer en premier
parce que notre partenaire américain a
joué un rôle extrêmement positif à cet
égard et comme vous le savez monsieur le
député le coq les déclarations
présidentielles supposent l'unanimité
des membres du Conseil de sécurité je
crois que c'est un signal important et
deuxièmement là aussi beaucoup
à l'instigation des États-Unis
d'Amérique les parties se sont réunis et
ont pris des engagements ces derniers
jours avec une trêve de plusieurs mois
c'est sans doute insuffisant
jugerez-vous mais ça n'était pas arrivé
depuis des années donc c'est ce genre de
choses qu'il faut encourager c'est un
mouvement que nous devons encourager si
on veut
œuvrer à la des escalades et restaurer à
nos horizons politiques le sol qui
permettra d'arriver à une solution juste
et durable donc avec deux états je tiens
à le redire le temps de me permettait
pas de revenir sur les propos du musc
israélien des Finances mais nous sommes
exprimés à titre national à sujet très
vite et dans des termes qui étaient
peut-être moins diplomatique que
d'habitude
merci merci
Réponse tout à fait intéressante pour le
groupe liotte c'est le président
penchère monsieur le député de la Meuse
madame la ministre
une crise ou décrit ce sont que des
menaces et des opportunités les menaces
on les voit bien le président Bourlanges
d'ailleurs nous les a tracé en détail il
y a comment il y a quelques instants on
a le sentiment vous écoutant que vous
avez conscience de ces menaces que vous
listez
les moyens d'éteindre ou les méthodes
pour éteindre partout les incendies on
n'a pas du tout une vision de ces
opportunités c'est à dire de ces
transformations du monde que pourrait
incarner que pour incarner la France la
France à l'intérieur de l'Europe et
l'Europe première puissance économique
mondiale mais nain politique nain
politique bon
ce qui serait intéressant pour nous ça
serait de comprendre
vos stratégies dans le domaine
quels sont ces objectifs en matière de
défense et en matière diplomatique le
calendrier enfin les moyens et le
calendrier pour atteindre tout ça on
serait peut-être pas d'accord mais ça
permettrait d'ouvrir un débat bon
deuxième comme en deuxième observation
l'Europe qui est un nain politique mais
un géant économique et qui pourrait
modeler le monde notamment par la France
et puis deuxième question l'Afrique on
perd
tous nos repères actuellement en Afrique
la même façon j'aimerais vous interroger
sur notre stratégie en Afrique quelles
sont nos objectifs ce sont des objectifs
en matière de de droit de l'homme des
promesses de droits de l'homme des
promesses de développement économique
des promesses d'échanges Nord-Sud des
promesses de développement de la
Francophonie enfin
quel est le message que l'on adresse
actuellement aux Africains et comment
pouvons-nous nous engager dans ce
domaine et enfin si il me reste quelques
quelques secondes je vais revenir sur le
déplacement du président de la
République en Afrique bon pourquoi ces
choix de pays et notamment lorsqu'il va
en République démocratique du Congo
pourquoi n'évoque-t-il que du bout des
lèvres les sanctions contre le Rwanda en
cas d'échec de la médiation congolaise
je rappelle que rapport des Nations
Unies de décembre 2022 prouve que le
Rwanda soutient les rebelles du M23 dans
la région du Nord qui vous
je vous remercie ces questions c'est
vrai que c'est vrai en Allemagne vous
êtes vous avez l'air un peu moins
angoissé dans vos réponses comme moi
dans mes questions
c'est un métier vous faites optimiste on
ne le ferait pas mais seul député merci
de nous rappeler l'étymologie du mot
crise mais il me semble pouvoir observer
que lorsqu'il y a trop de crise il y a
peut-être moins d'opportunités c'est
l'un de ces moments que nous vivons et
ces raisons pour laquelle au-delà des
réponses
que nous tenons apporter situation par
situation voire même des réponses
d'urgence je me suis employée à décrire
ce que nous essayons de faire sur le
long terme pour réduire ces fractures
éviter qu'il y en ait de nouvelles et
éviter que s'engage un nouveau et second
cycle de fragmentation conduisant à la
brutalisation alors en quelques mots
notre vision vous le savez mais je crois
que le Président de la République est
quelques autres se sont exprimés
régulièrement et clairement sur notre
vision c'est une France forte dans une
Europe forte et une Europe qui elle-même
devienne plus souveraines c'est tout
l'objet de l'agenda de Versailles c'est
ce que nous avons réussi à faire c'est
sûr que nous avons réussi sous
présidence française a amener nos
partenaires et avec une importance
plus grande qu'auparavant et même qu'il
y a quelques années était inimaginable
tant sur la composante de défense que
sur la composante industrielle
les
actions de l'Union européenne en termes
de
rein investissement de nos industries en
Europe sont à remarquer notamment la
dernière proposition de la Commission en
réponse à l'arrêt américain on pourrait
en parler longuement notre message aux
Africains monsieur j'ai vraiment essayé
de le décrire c'est un message de
partenariat de partenariat respectueux
de partenariats en ego ne venant pas duo
et considérant que nous avons nous avons
non seulement des atouts mais des
intérêts à défendre des valeurs aussi je
les dis et ne manquer jamais de penser
que nous parlons de tout dans notre
dialogue avec les pays africains enfin
sur le Rwanda
que vous dire je crois qu'il faut
reprendre les propos du président de la
République à ce sujet il a toujours été
tout à fait clair lorsqu'il s'est agit
de demander
le retrait du M23 publiquement et
également dans ses contacts avec le
président Kagame qu'il a vu à plusieurs
reprises en particulier sur ce sujet
j'en suis moi-même témoin
pour Renaissance madame lagraphie Amélia
c'est à vous merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre le président de la
République a effectué un déplacement de
plusieurs jours sur le continent
africain au Gabon en Angola en
République du Congo et en République
démocratique du Congo il avait avant
cela le lundi 27 février prononcé un
importante à locution à l'Élysée sur les
nouvelles impulsions données à notre
politique étrangère à l'égard des pays
du continent africain cette prise de
parole constitue une rupture celle de la
fin de la France Afrique et le Président
il y a énuméré plusieurs chantiers tout
d'abord de nouvelles modalités
concernant notre présence militaire afin
de mieux associer les armées des pays
africains ensuite la mise en valeur de
certains aspects de notre coopération
qui sont mal connues tant de nos
compatriotes que des Africains eux-mêmes
à ce titre le One forest Summit
co-organisé par la France symbolise
cette nouvelle approche qui passe par la
co-construction et le dialogue le chef
de l'État a aussi institué sur insister
sur le également nécessaire de notre
présence économique qui n'a fait que
décliner dans ce que beaucoup de grands
groupes voyaient comme leur pré carré
exclusif enfin cette relation
partenariale doit désormais s'inscrire
dans une logique de respect mutuel nous
avons tous observé en effet à quel point
les rancoeurs liés au passé ne demandent
qu'à être exploités
je tiens en revanche à souligner que
cette refonte de nos relations avec
l'Afrique s'inscrit aussi dans une
certaine continuité car c'est en réalité
dès 2017 que la France met en oeuvre
cette approche renouvelée le président
durant ce déplacement à toutefois
enfoncé le clou pour ce que pour que
cela soit bien clair auprès de ses
interlocuteurs et des opinions publiques
je souhaite toutefois en tant que élu
d'une circonscription comprenant les
trois quarts du contenu africain vous
interrogez sur une thématique à laquelle
je suis confrontée à chacun de mes
déplacements notre politique de
délivrance des visas extrêmement ferme
et souvent vécu comme une humiliation
par les ressortissants africains elle
est selon moi la cause la plus évidente
du ressentiment que l'on a parfois
regarde notre pays comment pourrait-on
améliorer le dispositif de traitement
des demandes qui je le rappelle pénalise
aussi les amis les conjoints voir les
enfants de Français installés en Afrique
je souhaite à cet égard avoir votre
sentiment sur la possibilité au moins un
titre expérimental de supprimer la
nécessité d'obtention de visa court
séjour pour les ressortissants du Gabon
et du Congo qui ne constitue pas un
risque majeur migratoire je suis à votre
disposition pour réfléchir à cette
proposition qui selon moi améliorer
notre image dans ces deux pays merci je
vous remercie madame la députée madame
la ministre
merci madame la députée il me faudra
toute votre aide et tout votre talent
pour convaincre mon collègue ministre de
l'intérieur du dernier point que vous
avez
sûre c'est bien pour ça que je fais
appel à son talent ceci dit c'est une
décision qui non seulement ne concerne
pas la ministre de la classe étrangère
seule mais elle ne concerne pas non plus
la France seule puisque les visages
Schengen c'est une décision Schengen et
donc
sois pas seul a décidé merci de ce que
vous avez dit madame la députée sur la
la refonte ou la refondation de notre
politique à l'égard du continent
africain je ne reviendrai pas sur vos
propos je ne répéterai pas non plus les
miens mais vous avez compris qu'il
s'agit de transformer notre notre
relation ça n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs que nous nous employons
puisque tout ceci est la déclinaison du
premier grand discours sur la politique
de la France à l'égard du continent
africain du président de la République à
Ouagadougou en 2017 mais nous voulons
aller plus loin nous avons adapté nos
instruments y compris le ministère des
armées j'en parlais mais compris mon
ministère et dans les points nouveaux
évoqué par le Président de la République
lors de son récent déplacement vous avez
vu que il y a le projet de présenter une
loi cadre sur les restitutions de bien
culturelles donc continuer de travailler
sur cette importante question de la
mémoire sur laquelle il faut d'un côté
comme de l'autre regarder des choses
avec peut-être mettre en plus de plus de
temps et de distance que nous n'avions
fait dans le passé et nous allons aussi
continuer à changer notre regard sur
l'Afrique
et continuer espérons-le à changer le
regard de certains segments de la
population africaine sur la France par
ce magnifique projet qui est la maison
des mondes africains qui devraient donc
dans un an répondre à cet objectif et
puis vraiment je voudrais revenir sur
l'intérêt de ces deux fonds que nous
avons créé parce que
nous devons au-delà des grands projets
pouvoir aider les petits entrepreneurs
africains et cette jeunesse qui a tant
d'idées alors les visas
c'est une équation compliquée parce
qu'il faut répondre aux demandes de ceux
qui de nos compatriotes qui veulent
avoir un accès à un service consulaire
efficace et rapide et être de
toute façon rigoureux comme il le faut
dans les contrôles de l'immigration
irrégulière et donc la conciliation des
deux objectifs et parfois un exercice
difficile en particulier dans certains
postes qui sont mal équipés on peut
équiper ce que nous avons fait madame
député c'est que j'ai demandé au service
concernés de mon ministère de regarder
et de d'aider les postes les plus
sollicités nous avons du fait de la
pandémie de la reprise des déplacements
après la pandémie parfois accumulées
notamment en Afrique subsaharienne de
gros retards et donc il faudra renforcer
ses postes avec des créations de poste
et je peux vous dire il y en aura
quelques-unes à la hauteur de nos moyens
mais quelques-unes dès l'été 2023 ça
c'est une décision que j'ai pu prendre
en début d'année grâce au budget
la loi de finances que vous aviez votée
et deuxièmement au-delà de de ces
renforcements qui seront qui
concerneront que quelques postes
évidemment
il faut
et ça c'est en œuvre depuis le début de
l'année ces missions de renfort qui
permettent de désengorger pardon du mot
mais déstocker là nous avions pris de
retard dans le traitement des demandes
du visa cela étant dit je reconnais que
toute œuvre humaine est un parfaite et
que
parfois nous pourrions être encore plus
efficace
et donc on va essayer aussi d'optimiser
de flux plus difficile le traitement des
demandes de visa notamment pour que les
délais d'examens soient moins longs si
c'est possible
pour assurer madame madame madame madame
madame lagraphie elle lui disant que les
services de l'immigration n'ont pas dans
ce pays le monopole de l'éternité
administrative je crois que c'est une
tendance assez générale du pays
pour le rassemblement national c'est
Monsieur fait faire
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre notre pays n'a plus de vision à
long terme sur rien mais depuis
longtemps mais votre gouvernement encore
aggravé ce constat politique énergétique
inflation industrie française
stratégique et le triste des placements
du président Macron en Afrique la
rappeler plus aucune vision à long terme
non plus en matière de diplomatie le
président la lui-même dit avec fierté à
plusieurs reprises il n'y a plus de
politique africaine de la France mais
finalement le problème est bien là car
si la France n'a aujourd'hui plus
d'ambition plus le moyen de ses
ambitions en Afrique nous pensons nous
qu'une politique africaine gagnante pour
tous peut exister à notre initiative
sans être ni condescendante ni
paternaliste depuis le discours de
Ouagadougou en 2017 ça a été évoqué qui
était censé redonner un élan à la
politique française en Afrique l'échec
est considérable avec le retrait et
l'arrêt de l'opération barkhane qui ne
donne plus la possibilité à notre armée
d'intervenir contre le djihadisme citons
aussi le Mali ou le Burkina Faso duquel
nous avons été prié de partir voir
disons le carrément chassé échec ici au
Maghreb où nous avons réussi la
performance diplomatique d'être en froid
à la fois avec l'Algérie et avec le
Maroc qui nous a rappelé publiquement
que nos relations n'étaient ni bonnes ni
amicales pendant ce temps partout la
concurrence ferrage Chine Russie et même
d'autres pays européens réussissent
mieux que nous en Afrique preuve que le
contexte instable n'est pas toujours la
cause de tous nos déboires permettez-moi
de vous poser une première question
madame la ministre sur nos perspectives
à Djibouti ou le traité de défense liant
nos deux pays arrivent à son terme en
2024 ce qui laisse peu de temps comparer
autant diplomatique et qui nous inquiète
alors que la Chine y développe une base
militaire et vient d'obtenir un accord
pour la création de la première base de
lancement spatial en Afrique
le grand discours et le voyage du
président Macron était là pour tenter de
reconstruire une diplomatie africaine en
souffrance pourtant j'ai bien peur que
nous n'en retenions seulement le manque
de respect voir le mépris face au
président congolais et les séquences
médiatiques catastrophiques dont
certaines attitudes que je qualifierais
pudiquement de nom présidentiel
madame la mini je termine sur nos
relations avec l'Algérie vous avez dit
que les déplacements du président et de
la première ministre il y a quelques
mois était là pour tracer des relations
sur le long terme mais l'échec semble
total sur le temps court confirmez-vous
la fin de la délivrance de laisser
passer consulaire à la France depuis
plus d'un mois et quelle initiative la
France va prendre pour débloquer cette
situation qui empêche rappelons le tout
exécution des aucutf qui devait pourtant
être exécutées à 100% selon les
désormais vieille promesse que plus
personne ne croit du président et de
Monsieur Darmanin je vous en remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le député madame
la ministre c'est à vous merci Monsieur
président merci monsieur fait faire
permettez-moi d'observer que je vous
trouve injuste mais vous ne serez pas
d'accord avec moi évidemment parce que
la vision existe bel et bien le
président de la République l'a décliné
de façon précise pendant une heure et
demie ou deux heures devant
un ensemble qui comprenait je pense
certains d'entre vous et devant la
presse également
je ne veux pas reprendre vos
commentaires sur ce point alors la
déclinaison est en cours je l'ai dit
moi-même et nous cherchons en effet
est-ce que ce soit gagnant-gagnant qu'il
n'y ait pas de politique africaine ou
plus de petites Catherine ne veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas de politique avec
l'Afrique ou que l'Afrique n'a plus
d'importance ou que le rapport avec les
pays africains n'ont plus d'importance
ne soyez pas sophistes
nous voulons voir ce continent pour ce
qu'il est et ces pays pour ce qu'ils
sont et il est temps avec leurs
difficultés avec leurs opportunités je
n'y reviens pas
l'Algérie je me suis exprimé tout à
l'heure en rappelant que au delà des
moments qui peuvent être parfois des
moments d'incompréhension de votre part
de la relation nous devons tous
travailler chacun à notre place pour que
cette relation qui est une relation de
long terme
servent les deux côtés de la
Méditerranée pour le Maroc je n'ai lu
que des commentaires de presse et je ne
crois pas que la France ait eu quelques
initiative que ce soit qui pourrait
provoquer lire des autorités marocaines
si je me trompe c'était moi lesquels je
n'ai pas d'informations sur la
délivrance ou la non délivrance des
laissez-passés mais je vérifierai auprès
de mon collègue ministre de l'Intérieur
ce qu'il en est de ce point j'en viens à
Djibouti ou la présence chinoise était
appelée depuis quelques années vous me
l'accorderez si vous m'interrogez plus
précisément non pas sur ce point mais je
voudrais observer que si je me suis
rendu avec ma collègue allemande
d'ailleurs en Éthiopie c'est peut-être
aussi en pensant au rôle des tas de
chair dans la Corne de l'Afrique et la
présence que doit y assurer l'Union
européenne en général et nos pays en
particulier sur l'accord de
défense
que la France a avec Djibouti je peux
vous dire que les discussions sont en
cours avec ce pays pour le
renouvellement de cet accord et pour ma
part j'ai tout à fait bon espoir qui
sera renouvelé
je vous remercie
c'est maintenant pour la France
insoumise c'est Madame merci à soudé
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre suite à l'attaque ayant coûté
la vie à deux colles ou Ara d'autres
colons israéliens ont décidé de riposter
attaquant cette même localité en faisant
un mort des centaines de blessés et en
incendiant à peu près tout sur leur
passage de nombreux commentateurs
israéliens ont osé à ce propos
l'utilisation du mot de peaugrum le
ministre smotretch qui est aussi à la
tête du parti d'extrême droite sionisme
religieux a déclaré le village de Huara
doit être anéanti la France est de
nombreuses autres pays ont condamné
fermement tant les événements ne même
que ses propos ignobles et cela nous au
nord nous nous inquiétons cependant de
la participation du ministre smotrich à
la conférence du 19 mars organisé au
Pavillon des Princes à Paris quel est
votre opinion sur le sujet
comment expliquer par ailleurs étant
donné la gravité des événements et la
dérive fascisante du gouvernement
Netanyahou aucune sanction n'est encore
été prise il ne sache il ne suffit pas
de condamner la colonisation pour la
faire cesser il faut la sanctionner à ce
propos Carrefour qui est une entreprise
française a été épinglée par cette ONG
et syndicat dont la FPS la LDH la CGT
est solidaire pour son accord avec deux
entreprises israéliennes impliquées dans
la colonisation de la Palestine ce joint
commerciale est d'autant plus surprenant
que la même entreprise dénonçait
l'invasion de l'Ukraine et avait annoncé
se retirer de Russie quoi qu'il en soit
cela pourrait entraîner la poursuite des
dirigeants de Carrefour devant la Cour
pénale internationale la Convention de
Genève oblige les États à agir dans les
circonstances de grandes entreprises
contreviendrait aux droits international
humanitaire que compte donc faire la
France autre sujet d'importance la
situation politique au Sénégal avec la
répression qui s'abat sur l'opposition
avec notamment l'arrestation arbitraire
d'Ousmane Sonko extrême à numilitary de
son véhicule cela devrait inciter le
gouvernement à revoir sa position sur la
convention française en matière pénale
et d'extradition qu'en pensez-vous
madame la ministre j'aimerais aussi vous
interroger sur le récent séisme qui a
occasionné plus de 50 000 morts en
Turquie et en Syrie pouvez-vous nous
indiquer qu'elles soutien a été apporté
par la France dans ces événements
dramatiques par ailleurs les conditions
d'octroi de visa ont-elles été
facilitées pour les victimes souhaitant
rejoindre leur famille en France au
moins de façon temporaire
enfin madame la ministre je vous
remercie de nous avoir tenu informé de
l'avancement des états généraux de la
diplomatie nous dirons le rapport avec
intention alors que depuis quelques
années les crises internationales qui se
succèdent nourrissent une forme
d'angoisse sur l'avenir du monde et de
la France je m'interroge sur
l'affaiblissement de notre corps
diplomatique et de ses moyens
un mot
de passer la parole à la mise sur l'aide
à la Turquie on a quand même consacré
une réunion la semaine dernière à
entendre effectivement les représentants
du ministère expliqué ce qu'ils ont fait
d'informations
reprendre si c'est nécessaire je vous en
prie madame la ministre merci Monsieur
prudent merci madame la députée soudée
quatre questions en deux minutes
ça m'oblige à faire des réponses que
vous jugerez peut-être trop lapidaire
ma vie peut-être que Madame soudé je
vais vous laisser à tout un peu plus de
temps merci Monsieur président d'avoir
arrêté le chronomètre pour cette
observation qui mue privée si vous ne
l'aviez arrêté d'au moins trois secondes
alors je vais reprendre ces questions
dans l'ordre madame la député les propos
vous m'offrez l'occasion de revenir sur
les propos du ministre israélien des
Finances j'avais pas pu répondre
complètement tout à l'heure tout en
rappelant que nous nous étions exprimés
à titre national d'une façon
particulièrement claire et
non seulement elle le fut je vais
revenir mais elle a entraîné les
remerciements de la part de la partie
Palestiniens nous avons dit que nous
étions concernés par ces propos qui sont
je peux le répéter des propos
inacceptables irresponsables et indigne
de la part d'un membre du gouvernement
israélien qui plus est à membre du
gouvernement israélien qui est chargé de
l'administration civile
des territoires
occupés donc ce type de propos ne fait
que
encourager et attiser la haine et
contribue à alimenter cette engrenage la
violence dont j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait qu'il s'arrête pour ce qui
concerne le Sénégal j'ai répondu assez
largement je pense à vos interrogations
en répondant à l'un des députés tout à
l'heure nous sommes attachés à l'état de
droit là comme ailleurs et nos dialogues
avec le Sénégal comme avec d'autres pays
nous permettent d'aborder toutes les
questions même les plus sensibles le
respect de la liberté de la presse ne
fait pas partie des questions
particulièrement sensibles donc nous
l'abordons tout à fait volontiers pour
les visas et les suites du séisme ce que
nous avons fait madame la députée c'est
de demander à nos postes diplomatiques
et consulaires sur place de traiter les
demandes des victimes ou des familles
des victimes de séisme
se rendre en France de façon accélérée
en particulier quand ces personnes ont
des proches en France qui peuvent ou qui
pourraient les accueillir cela dit
il s'agit d'un dispositif d'accélération
mais pas d'un dispositif
dérogatoire nous appliquons et nous
appliquerons le droit commun les
instructions en ce sens donc pas changer
si ce n'est la demande de faire vraiment
au plus vite et en considérant notamment
la possibilité pour les personnes
devenir pour les États généraux merci de
votre question madame la députée car
vous m'offrez la possibilité de dire ce
que je n'ai point dit tout à l'heure à
savoir que ce rapport lorsqu'il me sera
remis officiellement peut-être
dès la semaine prochaine en tout cas
vraiment
les quelques temps qui viennent je
compte tout à fait le rendre public oui
je vous remercie maintenant c'est
Monsieur Dumont pour les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre vous l'avez compris que les
propos de ma collègue Annie Genval lors
des questions gouvernement cet
après-midi les députés du groupe LR sont
particulièrement inquiets du fiasco de
la politique menée par le Président de
la République et son gouvernement en
Afrique la récente tournée en Afrique du
président Macron a malheureusement mis
en lumière de façon cruelle les
résultats de la politique menée sur le
continent depuis 6 ans une politique
faite de paternalisme de redomontade de
familiarité d'aveuglement et d'insolence
du Burkina Faso à la RDC du Maroc à
l'Algérie en passant par le Mali le
Gabon ou la Centrafrique partout où il
passe le président Macron endommage nos
relations diplomatiques affaiblit la
voie de la France et abandonne la
francophonie les quelques minutes à
louer ne me permettent pas de revenir
sur la situation dans chacun des pays
évoqués cependant je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur la crise diplomatique
ouverte avec l'un de nos plus fidèles et
ancien partenaire en Afrique le Maroc
après avoir qualifié ces relations
personnelles avec le roi du Maroc de je
cite amical le président de la
République a subi un double démenti le
de la part de Rabat d'abord dans un
article publié dans Jeune Afrique ou une
source officielle au sein du
gouvernement marocain affirmait que le
relation ne sont je cite ni amical ni
bonne pas plus entre les deux
gouvernements contre le Palais Royal et
l'Élysée puis lors de son séjour au
Gabon où le roi du Maroc aostensiblement
évité de croiser le président de la
République il s'agit de la pire crise
diplomatique entre nos deux pays depuis
la fin des années 1980 Madame le
Ministre le Royaume du Maroc est un
partenaire essentiel pour notre pays
tant dans le pourtour méditerranéen
qu'en Afrique pourquoi la politique
menée par la France vis-à-la
systématiquement sapé des décennies
d'amitié avec le Maroc ces tensions ne
sont pas des rumeurs de presse pour
reprendre vos mots cela fait par exemple
trois mois que le Maroc n'a pas nommé
d'ambassadeurs en France il est temps
d'engager le plus rapidement possible la
des escalade et il appartient à votre
ministère d'agir en ce sens ma question
est donc simple comptez-vous agir pour
retrouver une relation saine et
respectueuse avec le Maroc avant que le
Président de la République est fini de
s'aborder entièrement ce précieux
héritage et si oui comment
vous pouvez répondre à l'interpellation
virile du député du Pas-de-Calais
toujours je sais pas ce que vous
entendez par virer le seul président il
a été clair je n'en doute pas mais la
veille de la Journée internationale des
droits des femmes je ne vais pas
commenter plus avant ce qualificatif
pardon
j'avais pas vu j'étais mal placé sans
doute non ça n'est pas mon style
monsieur les petits vous vous
m'interrogez sur l'Afrique je crois en
avoir parlé assez longuement et dans ma
présentation luminaire et en réponse
déjà un certain nombre de questions qui
ont été posées sur les déplacements du
président de la République je crois
qu'il faudrait
le lire ou l'entendre plutôt que lire
les articles de presse au moins vous
auriez la version originale et peut-être
un jugement un peu différent
sur le Maroc je vous redis ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure les propos
désagréables que j'ai pu lire comme vous
parce qu'il m'arrive aussi de lire la
presse sont des propos que nous avons vu
dans un article de presse d'une source
anonyme aux demandes merci de l'avoir
appelé il y a un instant je n'y écart de
donc pas d'importance particulière je
reste sur ce que nous avons échangé avec
nos amis et homologues marocains lorsque
je me suis déplacée sur place le 15
décembre si c'était bien le 15 et pour
le reste de vos interpellations je
voudrais vous les retourner
vous les avez prononcés comme si vous
considériez que c'était la France qui
était à l'origine d'une difficulté
je vous demanderai pourquoi
j'en dis pas plus
je ne dirai rien parce que je ne dirai
rien parce que
je ne dis rien mais j'avais
effectivement un peu la même
interrogation que vous en disant que
dans une crise internationale dans une
dans des difficultés internationales moi
je fais quand même cette brève
intervention si vous me permettez nous
avons une situation je l'ai pas
dissimulé dans ma présentation originale
une situation très difficile pour la
France je crois et pour l'Europe et pour
l'Occident on peut
raisonner simplement sur l'air de nos
valeurs d'ordre depuis
1989 jusqu'à maintenant c'est une peau
de chagrin donc nous sommes dans une
situation difficile je crois que dans
une situation investir on a toujours des
responsabilités on n'est pas les seuls à
avoir ses responsabilités et il y a des
tendances très profondes et très longues
je crois que cet échange entre vous
permet de les de les éclairer je voulais
simplement dire ça
le vote du groupe Rignoux de la majorité
présidentielle au sein du Parlement
européen ce sont des sujets je n'ai pas
apporté le jugement de valeur dessus je
vous dis que c'est probablement des
sujets qui ont pu hériter c'est très
clair je vous remercie de se
rééquilibrage
madame
sur les parfumées sont sans feu cette
formule amuse toujours parce que vous
savez que c'est la formule que au moment
de l'affaire Stavinski quand on disait
avait dit Alfred Dreyfus ce qui dans son
cas est assez particulier
madame Gatel pour le pour le groupe
démocrate modem je regarde je suis pas
sûr que
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci Madame la Ministre alors vous
n'êtes pas parvenu à lever les
inquiétudes que nous avons sur les
déséquilibres du monde en revanche je
voudrais vous adresser nos sincères
remerciements pour ce tour d'horizon
extrêmement éclairant sur la situation
du monde alors au cœur de des différents
terrains de déstabilisation il y a
l'Iran vous l'avez évoqué et donc je
concentrerai mon intervention sur sur le
sur ce pays et je voudrais en premier
lieu avoir une pensée évidemment pour
les noces otages pour Benjamin Brière
qui a été acquitté mais qui est toujours
emprisonnée alors
s'ajoute aux inquiétudes sur le plan du
nucléaire iranien et vous l'avez
également évoqué
ce qui se passe depuis quatre mois c'est
mystérieux empoisonnement au gaz dans
les écoles de jeunes filles qui se sont
accélérées ces derniers jours désormais
ces faits sont reconnus officiellement
par le régime et ils auraient fait 5000
victimes parmi les jeunes filles dans 25
province c'est à dire quasiment
l'intégralité du pays 230 écoles étant
les journalistes que les lanceurs
d'allèles d'alerte ou encore les jeunes
filles qui dénoncent ce qui s'est passé
peuvent être conduits à être emprisonnés
alors aujourd'hui même il y avait une
grève lancée par le conseil syndical des
enseignants pour condamner ces attaques
chimiques et pour soutenir ces jeunes
filles et on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
ne pas imaginer que ces attaques sont
réalisées pour éloigner les jeunes
filles de l'éducation alors le
la question du nucléaire évidemment la
question la question de ces
empoisonnements auxquels s'ajoutent
évidemment les répressions les
arrestations arbitraires depuis six mois
et je voulais vous parler de la question
des corps des Gardiens de la Révolution
et de son classement en organisation
terroriste à la suite de du vote de la
résolution au Parlement européen qui a
été voté
écrasante majorité alors on le sait
Joseph Borel a indiqué qu'il y avait
besoin d'une décision de justice mais ça
ne semble pas être le cas on sait
également que l'Union européenne est
extrêmement divisée sur cette question
alors comment pouvons-nous
avancer sur sur cette reconnaissance
d'organisation terroristes au regard de
la déstabilisation de la région et du
soutien du corps des Gardiens de la
Révolution à certains mouvements
terroristes et j'ajouterai une très
brève question à la veille de
l'organisation des JO et à la suite du
rapport de la Cour des comptes sur la
question de la sécurité je voulais
savoir madame la ministre si vous
pouviez éclairer la Commission sur la
stratégie de lutte contre les intrusions
technologiques par des pays tiers je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
députée de Paris
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Députée je vous
demanderai votre indulgence pour ce qui
est de la dernière question
n'étant pas en mesure de vous répondre
donc c'est remis à une date ultérieure
que nous adressons à l'ensemble
avant même cette échéance
à l'interpellation de la député et je
suis sûr
à l'intérêt de tout le monde ici merci
Madame la député d'avoir évoqué les
situations de nos
otages en Iran
et c'est un sujet sur lequel vous avez
nous avons réussi à
faire adopter par l'Union européenne une
attitude plus nette en ce que désormais
les 27 par là d'une politique totale
c'est une chose que nous avons emportée
et si nous avons pu nous réjouir de la
libération de Madame fariba delka elle
n'est pas encore en mesure complètement
de joueurs de sa liberté puisque je ne
sais pas au moment où je vous parle si
elle peut quitter l'Iran c'est une chose
que nous employons à vérifier et puis il
reste en effet si otages je vous
remercie de penser à eux nous demandons
de façon régulière leur libération
immédiate et sans condition je me suis
exprimée très brièvement sur les
empoisonnements qui semblent
toucher les écoles iraniennes en
particulier les jeunes filles nous avons
pour le moment uniquement des
informations qui viennent
des réseaux sociaux et de la presse et
nous souhaitons que la lumière soit
faite sur ces événements qui sont
effectivement
des amis qui durent depuis le mois de
septembre donc avec une concomitance
dans le temps avec le mouvement de
protestation lancé par les femmes des
épisodes qui touchent essentiellement
des jeunes filles et qui semble
peut-être s'accélérer donc qui nous
semble indispensables qu'il y ait une
enquête sérieuse qui soit menée sur ce
sujet puisque désormais les autorités
iraniennes reconnaissent qu'il y a un
phénomène
troublant je reprendrai votre expression
monsieur le président
pour vous répondre sur le corps des
Gardiens de la Révolution deux choses
peut-être à avoir en tête le corps des
Gardiens de la révolution en tant que
corps et d'ores et déjà sous sanction
européenne au titre d'un autre régime et
compte tenu de l'appui qu'il avait
apporté aux activités de prolifération
iraniens donc ce corps est sous sanction
européenne si la question se pose de
plus de le mettre sous les mêmes
sanctions à notre titre elle est
peut-être symbolique mais d'une
importance pratique relativement limitée
par de le rappeler le corps est sous
sanction et un certain nombre
d'individus appartenant à ce corps ont
été sanctionnés de plus récemment
l'opinion qu'a exprimer monsieur Borel
ne fait que refléter l'opinion du
service juridique du conseil qui indique
qu'il n'est pas possible s'il n'y a pas
eu d'action justice engagée et même
terminée je crois dans un des États
membres que l'Union européenne puisse le
mettre sous ce régime particulier alors
nous nous en tenons
à cet avis il peut se faire qu'il y ait
dans
des jours les semaines des mois qui
viennent une telle l'action en justice
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui mais je
tiens à répéter que et le corps en tant
que tel et la plupart de ces
responsables sont à un titre ou un autre
sanctionné par l'Union européenne
je vous remercie maintenant le dernier
des intervenants au titre des groupes et
non pas en représentation d'un groupe
pour ce qu'il concerne monsieur
Dupont-Aignan merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je ne sais
pas si je dois vous admirer ou vous
plaindre ou les deux à la fois sans
doute parce que cela doit être très dur
d'être la ministre des frères étrangères
d'un président qui ridiculise la France
quand il se déplace qui
a commis une faute grave en RDC
notamment en ne voulant pas dire ce que
vous avez dit et je vous en remercie que
le Rwanda alimente et soutient les
rebelles et ça a été l'objet de
l'incident qui en fait a perdu sa
crédibilité notamment au Maghreb puisque
il s'est lancé sans certitude dans une
politique
de excessive à l'égard de l'Algérie et
il a perdu sur les deux tableaux
mécontent les uns et les autres alors on
comprend qu'il voulait supprimer le
corps diplomatique puisque manifestement
il n'est pas doué pour cela
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus grave
encore et c'est pour ça que ça doit être
dur pour vous à moins de vous en
satisfaisiez c'est qu'il y a pas de
politique étrangère de la France
sur l'Ukraine une chose est de défendre
l'intégrité de l'Ukraine une autre et de
suivre aveuglément ceux qui veulent
prendre une revanche contre la Russie et
entraîner l'Europe dans une guerre
d'usure contraire à nos intérêts
fondamentaux comme en témoignent le
déclassement de l'Europe sur le plan
économique industriel dont profite les
États-Unis et la Chine et moi je
voudrais vous poser une question très
précise pourquoi tantôt les déclarations
l'autorisation de Monsieur zeninski pour
proposer un plan de paix c'est ce qu'a
dit le président Macron en disant le
temps n'est pas venu de la paix
j'attends de le plan de paix de Monsieur
zeninski mais la Turquie Israël la Chine
reprennent le rôle qu'avait la France
quand il y avait Dominique de Villepin
ou Jacques Chirac sans remonter à de
Gaulle qui était d'avoir une parole
libre et indépendante qui n'écrit pas de
soutenir l'Ukraine mais après qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on attend
l'autorisation des États-Unis de Madame
anderleyen quel est votre politique pour
l'après quel est le plan de paix que la
France pourrait proposer pour
réconcilier
les protagonistes de cette tragédie rien
donc moi j'aimerais savoir comment vous
voyez ensuite la vision comme le disait
notre collègue monsieur penché mais en
fait vous ne pouvez pas en avoir puisque
le président des autorise pas en avoir
une il n'en a pas lui-même après j'ai
une question précise beaucoup plus
aimable
rassurez-vous qui est sur le Mercosur
j'ai appris que la France avait laissé
dissocier l'accord commercial avec le
Chili dissocier ça veut dire que on
accepte une partie commerciale qui se
prend la majorité et l'autre à
l'unanimité ça veut dire qu'on abandonne
le droit de veto sur la corde je
voudrais savoir sur le Mercosur la
commission a donné ses intentions de
dissocier l'accord de manière à le faire
avaliser ce qui empêcherait le véto de
la France et j'aimerais savoir quelle
est la position du gouvernement français
c'est-à-dire est-ce que le gouvernement
français gardera la volonté d'unité de
l'accord ou acceptera ça c'est pas
ration je ne suis pas sûr que la
question la plus agréable soit vraiment
la plus agréable
je ne veux pas sembler qu'elles étaient
si désagréables le moment où Monsieur le
Député vous avez été désagréable et
quand vous avez qualifié la tournée du
chef de l'État en Afrique et sachez que
c'est uniquement par souci de ne pas
polémiquer que je ne vous répondrai pas
avec vivacité sur le jugement que vous
avez porté qui est tout à fait hors de
mon raisonnement
soyons clair monsieur le député sur
l'Ukraine d'abord je suis heureuse de
vous entendre dire qu'il faut défendre
l'intégrité de l'Ukraine c'est une
évolution positive pour ce qui vous
concerne j'en prends acte mais
j'aimerais que vous soyez encore plus
clair et que vous vouliez bien
considérer que dans cette guerre il y a
un agresseur et un agressé et que cette
agression avec la procédé la Turquie la
Russie je suis réellement fatigué par
les décalages horaire et quelques nuits
passaient dans l'avion pardonnez-moi de
cela
cette agression caractérisée n'appelle
pas que vos métiers sur le même plan
l'agresser et l'agresseur la Russie
viole les principes les plus
élémentaires du droit international viol
ses propres engagements d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle avait pris au moment de la
disparition de l'Union soviétique et il
convient oui je le redis de défendre du
GRAINE parce que au-delà de l'Ukraine ce
que nous défendons c'est la paix et la
stabilité dans le monde je redis que si
les agressions étaient récompensées là
où elles se sont produites aujourd'hui
elles se reproduirait ailleurs c'est une
lotion de l'histoire je crois qu'il n'a
pas besoin de revenir sur notre passé
pour le rappeler
sur le respect du droit international je
vous entends dire que
il faudrait attendre que l'Ukraine soit
disposée à faire la paix alors je crois
utile pour votre information mais pour
l'information de la Commission de
rappeler que le président zellenski
puisque vous parlez de lui a toujours
recherché le dialogue et que ce n'est
jusqu'en février il inclus et que ça
n'est pas lui qui a déclenché une
agression de même je crois devoir vous
rappeler qu'il a présenté un plan de
paix au mois de novembre au mois de
novembre
lorsqu'il appartient lorsqu'il a été
invité à participer au G20 plante P que
nous soutenons et qui a trouvé une
déclinaison dans les termes qu'on
choisit
les négociateurs à l'Assemblée générale
des Nations unies dans la résolution
adoptée le 23 février en revanche
monsieur le député je le redis comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure la Russie ne
semble pas d'avoir pour le moment en
tout cas de disposition particulière
pour la paix pour la recherche d'un
dialogue elle n'en donne en tout cas
aucun signe il suffit d'entendre les
propos répétés du prénom Poutine ou de
Monsieur midwedef pour considérer que en
effet elle est tout à fait dans une
logique
identique à celle qui a
présidé à son agression c'est-à-dire une
logique impérialiste que nos analyses et
non pas de recherche de paix
votre question portée aussi sur le
Mercosur mais j'ai parlé trop longuement
si nous avons
sur le Chili accepté que cet accord soit
par effet c'est tout simplement il faut
quand même l'avoir en tête parce que le
Chili avait accepté ce que nous lui
demandions en tant que européen de
respecter à savoir les exigences
environnementales et sociales de tout
accord commercial de nouvelles
générations et le Chili en particulier a
accepté de faire référence au nécessaire
respect de l'accord de Paris sur le
climat et de ce qu'il entraîne dans les
flux commerciaux votre question portée
sur l'accord Mercosur qui est une
perspective plus lointaine parce que le
Mercosur est composé de plusieurs pays
et des négociations sont parfois
compliquées par le fait qu'ils n'ont pas
tous la même vue sur ces négociations je
vous réponds sur le point qui était
celui de votre interrogation nous sommes
opposés à la dissociation dans le cas de
ce futur accord si accord il y a nous
avons je crois par la voie du président
de la République lui-même rappeler cette
position au moment du Salon de
l'Agriculture lorsque le président s'est
rendu mais je vous le confirme
volontiers
une réponse précise maintenant les
groupes se sont exprimés j'ai quelques
parlementaires qui souhaitent vous
interroger madame la ministre
personnelle et le premier d'entre eux et
Monsieur François Thibault qui est
membre du rassemblement national
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues le 24 février dernier en
s'abstenant sur la résolution non
contraignante exigeant un retrait
immédiat des troupes russes l'Inde c'est
à nouveau distingué par ça neutralité
évidemment avec des guillemets dans le
conflit en Ukraine alors New Delhi est
devenu aujourd'hui un partenaire
économique majeur de la Fédération de
Russie notamment en matière
d'approvisionnement d'hydrocarbures
l'Inde profite de l'effondrement du
cours du pétrole qui est lié aux
sanctions occidentales pour augmenter
ses importations ainsi elle a apporté
1,2 millions de barils de pétrole par
jour en décembre soit 29% de plus qu'en
novembre 2022 alors qu'elle n'apportait
que 1% du Patrol Brutus avant la guerre
cette part atteint 18% en avril 2022
alors l'Inde sert aujourd'hui clairement
de plateforme afin de raffiner tout le
pétrole russe dont elle se gave à des
prix défiant toute concurrence pour les
revendre à des prix exorbitants et comme
vous le savez il est impossible de
tracer l'origine du pétrole brut une
fois qu'il est à l'inverse du pétrole
une fois qu'il est racine raffiné alors
madame la ministre vous étiez en Inde la
semaine passée et alors que la France a
décidé de se passer du pétrole russe
afin de ne pas financer son effort de
guerre contre l'Ukraine est-ce que des
mécanismes ont été prévus par votre
ministère afin d'éviter que le pétrole
russe passait par un pays tiers ne soit
distribué en France je vous remercie
très bien merci excusez-moi monsieur
François de d'avoir interverti votre
prénom je n'ai même pas l'excuse du jet
lag de la ministre madame la ministre
c'est à vous de répondre
merci Monsieur
parfois auprès d'une certaine fatigue
c'est vrai dans le sens SOS a fini par
faire qu'on se retrouve à Paris monsieur
le député François l'Inde vous le savez
nous apprendrez rien à
traditionnellement ou historiquement en
tout cas des relations de proximité avec
la Russie et parallèlement des relations
plus difficiles avec la Chine ce qui
peut conduire à
avoir pour
dire les choses simplement sur le
conflit que la Russie engagé en Ukraine
des vues qui sont
un peu moins équilibré que les nôtres
néanmoins l'un d'un tout à fait assumé
comme il le fallait son rôle de
présidence nous avons pu lors du G20 de
la semaine dernière
tenter
de reprendre les paragraphes qui
convenaient sur la gravité du conflit
engagé par la Russie en Ukraine et en un
mot tenter de reprendre et mon homologue
indien c'est vraiment efforcé tenter de
reprendre le langage qui avait été agréé
par les dirigeants du G20 à la fin du
mois de novembre il a fait les
meilleures efforts pour cela il se
trouvait que le durcissement russe ne
lui a pas permis et que la Chine a
laissé les choses se faire peut-être en
considérant aussi que le G20 indien ne
méritait pas des efforts allant de là de
ce que son premier sentiment ludiqueté
pour ce qui est
[Musique]
du pétrole
les effets des sanctions et le fait que
les Européens ont réduit
fortement leur dépendance aux
hydrocarbures russes au point qui sont
désormais quasiment résiduelles vous le
savez on pourrait fait de faire baisser
les prix et donc il y a des pays qui
peuvent en effet acheter et ils ont le
droit de le faire à des prix plus
faibles qu'auparavant des hydrocarbures
eux-mêmes n'appliquant pas les sanctions
nous sommes vigilants sur le
contournement des sanctions et toutes
les dispositions sont prises à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas eu de
contournement qui concernerait
atteindrait infinie notre pays venant
des activités de de raffinage indienne
merci Madame la Ministre madame
Youssoufa Youssoupha décidément j'ai des
problèmes avec les merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre alors que
notre diplomatie dénonce régulièrement
l'influence russe en Afrique de l'Ouest
et ses attaques contre la France nous
sommes à Mayotte consternés par le
silence ambigu de vos services sur le
discours russe contestant Mayotte
françaises pour mieux légitimer son
agression de l'Ukraine pas un mot du
Quai d'Orsay sur les déclarations de
Sergueï Lavrov qui le 3 février dernier
a une nouvelle fois remis en cause le
département français de Mayotte et
soutenu les revendications illégitimes
des Comores en décembre c'est
l'ambassadeur russe à Moroni qui a
carrément proposé l'aide militaire pour
conquérir Mayotte le mois dernier les
Marines russes et chinoises ont organisé
des exercices militaires avec l'Afrique
du Sud dans le canal du Mozambique à
quelques centaines de kilomètres
seulement de Mayotte pour nous la menace
est très claire
ce 2 mars c'était l'organisation des
pays non alignés qui a renouvelé son
soutien à la souveraineté incontestée de
l'Union des Comores sur l'île de Mayotte
fin de citation et déclarait je cite à
nouveau sous domination coloniale
française face à ces attaques aucune
réaction du Quai d'Orsay ni de l'Élysée
je vous le demande ici madame la
ministre que répondez-vous à la
diplomatie russe que répondez-vous à
celles et ceux qui contestent Mayotte
dans la République qui conteste le choix
des mahorés de rester français ce qu'ils
sont depuis 1841 je vous remercie
merci Madame le député madame la
ministre très important de question mais
bien sûr merci Monsieur président merci
Madame la députés Youssoupha je vous
réponds très volontiers madame la
députée ne doutez pas un instant
c'est la position de la France je crois
que je dois vous répondre mais vous
savez que Mayotte est dans la République
et le restera je ne suis pas la seule à
vous le dire je crois l'avoir entendu
dans l'hémicycle aussi Mayotte et
française cela dit nous sommes
vigilants je devrais me dire inquiet
devant l'offensive russe partout en
Afrique et notamment oui vous avez
raison dans le canal du Mozambique là
comme ailleurs des campagnes de
désinformation et des messages
anti-français celui que vous évoquez en
fait partie et pardonnez-moi de ne pas
me livrer à l'exercice qui consisterait
à commenter toutes les déclarations du
ministre des Affaires étrangères russes
j'y passerai beaucoup de temps et je ne
veux pas non plus comment les siennes
lorsqu'ils parlent des nazis qui
seraient en
Ukraine et qui justifierait
l'agression russe alors ce que nous
faisons c'est que nous renforçons notre
coopération avec
l'homozambie avec Madagascar et avec
l'Afrique du Sud en particulier
notamment pour ce qui concerne notre
coopération avec le Mozambique en
matière de sécurité maritime et nous
avons avec avec l'Union européenne
déployée une mission de formation de
l'armée mozambicane avec
ce que je parle trop longtemps
avec l'Afrique du Sud j'espère madame la
député pouvoir me rendre avant l'été
nous entretenons là aussi un dialogue
régulier c'est une puissance régionale
une puissance régionale influente j'ai
tenu à mon tenir par exemple avec mon
homologue sud-africaine
la semaine dernière lorsque nous étions
ensemble à New Delhi afin notamment de
bien ajuster nos positions sur la guerre
en Ukraine elles ne sont pas
spontanément si vous considérez les
votes de l'Afrique du sudation unis et
puis avec Madagascar il y a un réseau de
coopération qui est dynamique une
communauté française également qui est
dynamique et vous savez que nous avons
un bureau de représentation de Mayotte à
Madagascar donc c'est un autre point
d'appui reste dans la député qu'il faut
continuer à renforcer notre dispositifs
pour être mieux équipés pour lutter
contre la désinformation russe et contre
les manipulations de l'information russe
là comme ailleurs c'est l'objet d'une
des transformations du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères que
de
viser à renforcer même modifier
considérablement nos méthodes de travail
ainsi que les moyens de la direction de
la communication et de la presse qui
pour ce qui concerne le ministère est
chargé il y a d'autres ministères qui
peuvent partager pour ce qui concerne
notre ministère est chargé de cela ces
moyens vont être renforcés vous verrez
elle aussi peut-être dans la suite des
États généraux ce que nous pensons à
faire
merci
je vous remercie monsieur le président
madame la ministre je cite les relations
ne sont ni amicales ni bonnes pas plus
entre les deux gouvernements contre le
Palais Royal et l'Élysée voilà ce que le
journal Jeune Afrique rapporte
concernant les relations
franco-marocaines alors j'ai deux
questions la première sur la réponse
diplomatique à cette déclaration d'une
source officielle marocaine que
comptez-vous faire pour rétablir des
relations apaisées avec le Maroc pays
historiquement émis de la France la
seconde sur la réadmission des
ressortissants marocains en situation
irrégulière sur notre sol en décembre
vous félicitiez de la fin de la crise
sur les visas et tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle vous avez dit je vous cite
nous regardons vers l'avenir car nous
avons une ambition forte au bénéfice de
nos peuples et en particulier pour nos
jeunesse la réduction de la moitié de
visa entre 2021 et 2022 a-t-elle porté
ses fruits concernant le nombre de
réadmissions et le taux effectif de
retour vers le Maroc merci de nous
communiquer des chiffres précis
je vous remercie madame la ministre
merci madame je réalise on vous
répondant que je suis obligé de vraiment
de parler avec un débit d'enfer ce qui
n'est pas très agréable pour vous mais
vous posez des questions pertinentes
importantes et nombreuses et dans les
deux minutes et dans la minute il est
difficile de faire mieux j'ai répondu je
non mais il y a aucune raison
je pratique l'apaisement mais je
souhaite répondre aussi précisément que
possible député
l'apaisement je le pratique avec le
Maroc comme je le pratique avec d'autres
pays je vous redis madame la députée que
si nous avons lu des déclarations
désagréables je crois avoir utilisé le
qualificatif dans la presse elles sont
de sources anonymes et
n'appelle pas mes yeux en tout cas à ce
titre de commentaire particulier
l'apaisement je crois l'avoir pratiqué
en me rendant au Maroc
mi décembre je redis que ça devait être
le 15 décembre mais vous vérifierez et
en me rend au Maroc avec un certain
nombre de dossiers que nous avons évoqué
dont le dossier qui permettait de
constater que d'un côté comme de l'autre
nous reprenions des relations
consulaires normales voilà ce que j'ai
pratiqué et je souhaite continuer pour
ma part à pratiquer le même apaisement
je réponds enfin à votre question sur ce
qui s'est passé dans le passé et je vous
réponds en disant madame la député que
non à ma connaissance pour vérifiera les
chiffres ça n'avait pas particulièrement
permis d'augmenter le taux de
réadmission ni dans ce pays ni dans un
autre ce qui est conduit d'ailleurs vous
l'avez vu à une évolution de notre
position
si vous pouvez nous donner ces chiffres
ce serait très utile voilà alors
maintenant j'ai monsieur fait faire j'ai
me poser un problème vous me posez un
problème parce que c'est un problème de
fond
vous vous êtes inscrit vous étiez
porte-parole de votre groupe puis vous
vous êtes inscrit dès le début comme
intervenant à titre individuel alors ça
ça va pas parce que c'est pas les titres
individuels c'est pas encore un peu de
rap monsieur kalbori c'est pas une
minute de plus on admet à titre
exceptionnel que si une question est
intervenue en cours de route et que on a
un peu de temps libre le on
réintervienne mais ça ne peut pas être
un principe pour les gens qui sont
intervenus au titre du groupe se
rajoutent après au titre au titre
individuel alors soit si vous avez une
question mais comme vous étiez inscrit
au début donc j'ai bien vu que vous vous
en rajoutiez une minute et et ça ne va
pas donc ce jeu je dis ça c'est vous
êtes vous êtes de ce point de vue là
comme dans les arrêts du Conseil d'État
victimes d'une d'une jurisprudence mais
en réalité je crois que c'est ça serait
pas de votre de bonnes politiques parce
que sinon ça se produirait
systématiquement et j'aurais deux listes
d'intervenants qui se qui se succéderait
mais si vous avez parce que après avoir
affirmé un principe je suis dans laxisme
et d'une faiblesse extravagante si vous
avez une question particulière qui vous
serait venue dans le courant en 30
secondes posez-la à Madame à Madame
la Ministre et puis après si j'ose dire
taisez-vous pour l'éternité dans ce
cadre là
merci monsieur le Président mais je
crois que le cas c'était déjà présenté à
d'autres reprises et le fait que je sois
intervenant choisi par mon groupe pour
interroger à la ministre l'influenrien
sur la question que je dois poser parce
qu'il a eu Kakou une illumination en
tout cas merci monsieur le Président
pour votre laxisme passager
madame la ministre en plus cette
question elle porte sur un sujet un peu
plus technique peut-être que vous
n'aurez pas la réponse immédiatement en
tout cas il est plus proche de nous
géographiquement mais qui vous concerne
en tant que député de la Moselle et qui
concerne aussi des milliers de
travailleurs des travailleurs
frontaliers au Luxembourg elle porte sur
la convention fiscale entre la France et
Luxembourg qui a été voté en 2018 mais
dont l'application avait été suspendue
en 2021 pour deux ans tant d'ailleurs
elle était pénalisante sur l'imposition
de certains catégories de frontaliers
qui disposaient de revenus mixtes en
France et au Luxembourg ou dont l'un des
membres du couple travaille en France en
effet de quelques centaines à quelques
milliers d'euros la facture d'impôt
avait été salée et les services de Bercy
devait réaliser une étude d'impact cette
étude n'a toujours pas été livrée
l'année fiscal déjà largement entamé il
ne reste qu'un mois avant le lancement
de la campagne déclarative des revenus
aussi madame la ministre je souhaiterais
savoir si vous pouvez nous confirmer
qu'il y aura une suspension pour une
année supplémentaire de cette
application en 2023 parce que nous
jugeons cette année supplémentaire
nécessaire pour pouvoir travailler sur
de nouvelles mesures pour éviter ces
brutales hausses merci monsieur le
Président merci Madame la Ministre voilà
une question dans le caractère technique
est assez évident
mais là si vous ne l'avez pas envoyé la
nous
un parfait mais je demanderai surtout à
Bercy de vous l'envoyer parce que c'est
sujets sont suivis par le ministère de
l'économie et des finances je vous
répondrai néanmoins dans les grandes
lignes puisque j'ai évoqué ce sujet il y
a moins d'un mois avec notre
ambassadrice au Luxembourg pays amis oui
on peut être ami avec quelques pays et
pays dans lequel les Français sont
particulièrement actifs grâce à
l'excellente coopération
transfrontalière que nous avons honoré
depuis plus de 10 ans grâce à ses
accords pour faire moins facétieux
désormais je portais en disant que nous
avons des discussions en cours
discussions qui sont menées par le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
avec les autorités luxembourgeoises sur
la convention fiscale bilatérale pour
voir précisément si elle correspond
toujours aux réalités d'aujourd'hui vous
avez évoqué quelques sujets et donc un
rapport doit être
remis sur les effets
d'un changement de méthode dans les tous
prochains jours au Parlement me signale
tant voilà j'espère qu'il est assez
complet bon écoutez dès qu'il y aura des
éléments nouveaux vous ne les fournirez
et monsieur
je vais faire n'aura pas intervenir une
troisième fois voilà mais merci merci
Madame la Ministre ces réponses
extrêmement extrêmement précises
développées tout à fait intéressantes je
crois que les parlementaires je le
disais au début les parlementaires ont
exprimé de différentes manières
notamment j'ai été très sensible à ce
qu'ils à ce qu'a dit Madame Youssoupha
sur les menaces
pesant sur l'île qu'il a envoyé ici
comme représentant de la France et mais
d'une façon générale vous avez trouvé
une une commission qui est préoccupée
par la dégradation de la situation
internationale
la difficulté d'y faire face et sans
doute la certitude que pour s'en sortir
il faudra il faut
trouver une dimension nouvelle selon moi
c'est peut-être pas la vie de tous les
membres de la commission cette dimension
ne peut être coréenne
mais
merci en tout cas d'être venu et nous
vous retrouverons
prochainement
car l'actualité
nourrit constamment notre hotte
que la haute du Père Noël
voilà la séance est levée